Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich berühse alle hier zur 45. Ausgabe. Heute hat mich der Weg wieder einmal nach München geführt, genauer nach Oberpfaffenhofen, hier dem großen DLR Standort, wo ich schon so häufig gewesen bin, aber wo es einfach gar keinen Mangel an neuen Themen und an noch unerforschten Instituten gibt. Heute steht in gewisser Hinsicht die Bildung ein wenig im Vordergrund, was man vielleicht so auf den ersten Blick gar nicht merkt, denn man könnte es auch genauso gut als Anschlusspodcast an unsere 26. Ausgabe sehen, forschen in Schwerelosigkeit. Eine der längsten Gespräche, glaube ich, die wir hier auch bisher geführt haben, eine wunderbare Reise durch die verschiedenen Anwendungen, wie man in Schwerelosigkeit forschen kann. Da wurden so am Rande auch ein paar Experimente mit Raketen erwähnt. Und das führt uns so langsam so ein bisschen zu dem Thema heute. Genauer soll es gehen um die Rexus-Bexus-Kampagnen. Und dazu bin ich, wie ich schon gesagt, jetzt in Oberpfaffenhofen angekommen, und zwar im Institut Moraba, mobile Raketenbasis. Und begrüße als Gesprächspartner heute Alexander Schmidt.
Hallo Tim.
Guten Tag. Ja, lange Rede, lange Einstiegsrede. Jetzt müssen wir mal glaube ich erst mal ein bisschen hören. Habe ich es richtig gesagt? Also ist das ein eigenes Institut, die mobile Raketenbasis?
Nein, das ist nicht ganz richtig in der Tat, sondern die mobile Raketenbasis ist eine Abteilung eines Instituts. Und zwar ist es das Institut für Raumflugbetrieb und Astronautentraining. Und ich glaube, mich erinnern zu können, dass du auch einen Podcast gemacht hast mit Florian Sellmeier von der Geschäftsfeldentwicklung dieses Institutes.
Genau, wo es um das GSOK im Wesentlichen ging.
Wo es um das GSOK ging. Und das GSOK ist ein Überbegriff für drei Abteilungen aus diesem Institut. Und die mobile Raketenbasis ist eine weitere Abteilung und ist auch ein bisschen eigenständig losgelöst von den Satellitenoperationen. Wir haben also nichts mit Satellitenoperationen, Kontrollräumen oder auch diesen Antennenstationen in Weilheim zu tun, sondern was wir machen ist, wir bauen und starten auch Forschungsraketen. Deswegen der Name mobile Raketenbasis.
Ja, die Sendung, auf die du dich beziehst, ist Raumzeit 36. Da ging es ums Raumfahrtkontrollzentrum im Wesentlichen. Es gab aber auch schon den Ausblick, dass dieses Institut sich auch um ganz andere Sachen kümmert. Die mobile Raketenbasis ist ja intern ein bisschen als die wahren Cowboys vertreten. Wenn ich das gut gelesen habe zwischen den Zeilen, hier wird noch richtige Raketentechnik gemacht. Rocket Science, wie man sich das so immer vorstellt.
Hier wird in der Tat richtige Raketentechnik gemacht. Ich glaube, das ist auch etwas, was uns entscheidend unterscheidet von anderen Raumfahrtinstitutionen. Also wie schon gesagt, wir bauen, konstruieren und starten auch Raketen. Wir machen das ungefähr zehn bis zwölf Mal im Jahr. Es gibt also verschiedene Projekte. Wir entwickeln die Hardware selber. Wir bauen auch die Hardware selber. Und wir bauen am Ende auch die Rakete selber zusammen. Und wir fahren auch am Ende an den Startplatz und starten die Rakete. Und wir machen auch die Recovery-Operation. Das heißt, meistens will man die Experimente oder die Nutzlast wieder zurückbekommen. Auch darum kümmern wir uns. Und dann fahren wir wieder nach Hause und warten auf das nächste Projekt. Es hat also schon so ein bisschen den Charme von Wildwestromantik. Zum Beispiel haben wir einen Startplatz in Kiruna, in Nordschweden. Da ist also im Wesentlichen nichts außer Wald. Und dieser Startplatz und die Ortschaft Kiruna oder Stadt Kiruna, da ist eine sehr große Eisenerzmine. Und der Kiruna hat ungefähr, ich glaube, 20.000 Einwohner. Und viel mehr gibt es da nicht, außer Bäumen und Hügeln und eben diesen Raketen-Startplatz noch. Und ja, da kann man dann schön in Ruhe seine Raketen bauen und starten.
Um es gleich nochmal gesagt zu haben, wir reden jetzt hier nicht von Raketen in der Größenordnung, wie sie in Kuro oder im Balkonur abgeschossen werden, sondern hier geht es um überschaubarere Maße, Raketen so in Lastwagenlänge. Bevor wir vielleicht nochmal auf die Details dieser konkreten Raketentechnik hier eingehen, würde mich nochmal so interessieren, was dich jetzt hier so hergeführt hat, auf welchem Ausbildungsweg du hier ins DLR reingesegelt bist und was so deine konkrete Aufgabe hier ist.
Ja, also es ist ganz klar, warum ich hier bin, ist natürlich Interesse und Leidenschaft für Raumfahrt. Ich denke, das verbindet die meisten Leute meiner Abteilung. Bei mir hat das Ganze eigentlich schon in früherer Kindheit angefangen. Ich habe mich schon immer begeistert, vor allem auch für bemannte Raumfahrt. Habe natürlich damals diese in Anfang der 80er, diese ersten Space Shuttle Missionen mitverfolgt. Zu Apollo-Zeiten war ich noch nicht geboren. Das habe ich mir dann aus Büchern angeeignet, dieses Wissen. Und diese ganze Raumfahrt und auch die Planeten- und Sonnensystemforschung, das hat mich schon sehr in den Bann gezogen. Und als es dann an Studieren ging, war für mich die Entscheidung eigentlich relativ klar. Ich möchte irgendwas studieren, was mich im Detail näher an diese Geschichten heranbringt. Und so kam es, dass ich dann angefangen habe, Physik zu studieren. Das ging dann schon ein bisschen weg von der Richtung Raumfahrt und Astronomie. Aber ich habe eben festgestellt, wenn ich genauer verstehen will, wie zum Beispiel Sterne aufgebaut sind oder warum sich Himmelskörner bewegen, wie sie sich bewegen, muss man sich mit Physik beschäftigen. Und dann bin ich noch ein bisschen weiter davon weggekommen, bin mehr Richtung Mathematik gegangen, mathematische Physik, weil mich dann eben fasziniert hat, die Naturgesetze und deren mathematische Beschreibung, die eigentlich hinter diesen Dingen steht. Und ich habe dann mein Diplom in Physik gemacht an der LMU in München. Dann habe ich noch eine Promotion daran gehängt. Und ja, eigentlich passend zu dem zu dem Titel dieses Podcasts, da habe ich mich also mit mathematischen Aspekten von Raum und Zeit in der in der fundamentalen Physik beschäftigt. Und das habe ich dann auch noch eine Zeit lang als Postdoc gemacht und habe mich da in der akademischen Welt ein bisschen umgesehen. Und irgendwann dachte ich mir, es muss nicht unbedingt eine akademische Karriere sein. Und in mir brannte schon noch irgendwie das Interesse für Raumfahrt. Und das ist ja auch die Zeit gewesen, so ab 2000, als dann die ISS zusammengebaut wurde. Das habe ich dann immer mitverfolgt. Und dann habe ich auch mitgekriegt, dass es hier eben dieses Columbus- Kontrollzentrum gibt. Und dann habe ich mir gedacht, warum nicht beim DLR bewerben? Und dann habe ich mich hier beim Institut für Raumflugbetrieb und Astronautraining beworben. Wurde dann bei der mobilen Raketenbasis genommen. Das hat mir natürlich von Anfang an zugesagt. Ich meine, man muss sich das mal vorstellen. Ich wusste ja vorher auch nicht, dass es diese Einheit gibt. Wir sind eine relativ kleine Einheit mit ungefähr 30 Mitarbeitern. Und was hier gemacht wird, ist wie vorher schon erwähnt, sehr exklusiv. Da wird ja dann erzählt, also hier werden die Raketen konstruiert, sie werden zusammengebaut und wir fahren auch in andere Länder, um dort die Raketen zu starten. Hier in Deutschland kann man offensichtlich keine Rakete starten, das wäre zu gefährlich, weil die gegen zu dicht besiedelt ist. Und ja, dann denkt man sich schon, ja, das ist doch ein cooler Job, also da bin ich dabei. Mobil heißt, also wie du schon gesagt hast, die Raketen, mit denen wir uns beschäftigen, das sind keine Raketen in der Größenklasse Ariane oder Soyuz. Ich sag mal, so ein Richtwert, eine Durchschnittsgröße, ist aber 8 bis 12 Meter vielleicht da. Und mobile Raketenbasis heißt, dass wir in der Lage sind, an jedem beliebigen Ort in der Welt, der zumindest logistisch erreichbar ist, mit Containern eine Rakete zu starten. Das heißt, wir haben mobiles Equipment. Es gibt mobile Launcher. Launcher ist das Gerüst, an dem man eine Rakete dranhängt. Dann haben wir mobile Stationen, Telemetriestationen, Radarstationen und das können wir alles vor Ort aufbauen. Wurde früher häufiger gemacht als heute. Es ist natürlich relativ bequem, auch schon vorhandene Infrastruktur zu nutzen. Deswegen fahren wir viel auf diese Range in Kiruna, S-Range genannt, steht für European Sounding Rocket Range. Sounding Rocket ist der englische Begriff für Höhenforschungsrakete. Im Nachbarland Norwegen gibt es auch eine Range, Andoja Rocket Range. Da wurde vor kurzem die sogenannte Chefex-2-Rakete gestartet. Das hat vielleicht der eine oder andere in den Wissenschaftsnachrichten mitgekriegt. Aber im Prinzip sind wir komplett mobil. Es wurden in früherer Zeit auch schon Kampagnen in Grönland durchgeführt, in der Antarktis, wo auch immer.
Findet das jetzt auch noch statt?
Wenn es denn das wissenschaftliche Ziel, was wir immer verfolgen, letztendlich sind wir Startdienstleister für Leute, die Experimente machen wollen, für Wissenschaftler, die ein wissenschaftliches Ziel verfolgen. Und wenn dieses wissenschaftliche Ziel es nach sich zieht, dass man an einen bestimmten Ort fahren muss, um dort diese Forschung zu machen, sei es etwa, weil dort gerade das Magnetfeld besonders stark ist oder weil man nur von dort aus irgendwie ein astronomisches Objekt besonders gut beobachten kann, was auch immer, dann können wir da hinfangen.
Und dann wird das auch getan?
Dann wird das auch getan.
Wie häufig ist das so? Ist das jetzt so wie bei der Feuerwehr, dass da so ein Anruf kommt, eins an zwei, und dann rutschen alle aus dem Messenstock über die Stangen runter?
Nein, ganz so schnell wie bei der Feuerwehr geht das natürlich nicht. Wie ich vorher schon gesagt habe, im Durchschnitt haben wir so 10, 12 Raketen im Jahr. Und die meisten werden eben auf diesen festen Ranges in Kiruna oder Norwegen gestartet. Andoia heißt der Ort. Auch in Brasilien gibt es Ranges, die genutzt werden. Ich bin jetzt seit vier Jahren in dieser Abteilung und ich kann mich nicht erinnern, dass wir in den letzten vier Jahren eine Kampagne gehabt hätten, wo wir nicht auf einer dieser Ranges gewesen wären. Aber es kann jederzeit wieder passieren.
Also es ist möglich, aber es steht jetzt nicht so im Fokus.
Das ist momentan anscheinend nicht gefragt, sagen wir mal so, ja.
Ja, jetzt hatte ich am Anfang mich auf den Podcast mit Forschung und Schwerelosigkeit bezogen. Das ist hier auch ein Aspekt, aber eigentlich geht es jetzt primär erst mal um Höhenforschung, richtig? Kann man das so sagen?
Also ich würde mal sagen, Höhenforschung ist nach meinem Verständnis kein definierter Begriff. Es war schon eigentlich treffender, diese Geschichte mit der Schwerelosigkeit. Was man mit diesen sogenannten Höhen, die heißen halt so Höhenforschungsraketen, was man mit diesen Raketen abdecken kann, das ist ein Bereich, den man sonst eigentlich nicht erreichen kann. Das heißt, man kann zum Beispiel mit Flugzeugen erreicht man Höhen von, was weiß ich, 15 Kilometer, 20 Kilometer. Mit Stratosphärenballonen erreicht man Höhen von 30, maximal 40 Kilometer, dann ist die Atmosphäre definitiv zu dünn, weil es dieses Konzept im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes nicht mehr trägt. Satelliten gehen in der niedrigen Höhe natürlich nicht, weil dafür die Atmosphäre wieder zu dicht ist und der Satellit sofort durch die Reibungshitze wieder auf die Erde runterspiralen würde. Das heißt, Satelliten gibt es normalerweise ab einer Höhe von 300 Kilometer, ist schon zu niedrig, glaube ich. Fast die ISS hat so um die 400 Kilometer, aber die müssen ihre Bahn schon alle paar Monate wieder um einige Kilometer erhöhen, sonst würde die auch relativ bald abstürzen. Und nun genau dieser Bereich dazwischen, zwischen 100 und 300 Kilometer, den erreicht man eigentlich nur mit diesen Höhenforschungsraketen. Und die Art der Experimente, die man auf diesen Raketen machen kann, ist natürlich sehr vielfältig. Und wenn man zum Beispiel atmosphärische Forschung betreiben will in diesem Höhenbereich, dann kann man das eigentlich nur mit so einer Sounding Rocket machen. Aber ein ganz, ganz großer Aspekt und eigentlich der größte Aspekt ist tatsächlich, dass diese Raketen dazu benutzt werden können, ein Experiment in Schwerelosigkeit oder wie wir es auch nennen, Micro-G durchzuführen.
Mikro-Gravitation. Mikro-Gravitation, also nicht so die totale theoretische, mathematische Abwesenheit von Gravitation.
Ja, Mikro heißt größenordnungsmäßig ein Millionstel der Schwerkraft, die wir auf der Erde spüren. Theoretisch Null kann man sowieso nicht erreichen, aber Mikro-G ist schon ziemlich gut. Übrigens auch ein Vorteil dieser Höhenforschungsraketen, dass wir eine sehr gute Qualität dieser Schwerelosigkeit haben. Wenn du zum Beispiel, ich weiß nicht, was ihr da alles angesprochen habt in diesem Podcast über Forschung in der Schwerelosigkeit, wenn du zum Beispiel einen Parabelflug machst, dann hast du natürlich das Problem, dass sich das Flugzeug nach wie vor in der Atmosphäre bewegt, dass sich in dem Flugzeug Leute bewegen und dass es dadurch Erschütterungen gibt. Die sind zwar klein, stören aber schon die Qualität der Schwerelosigkeit. Auch auf der ISS ist es so, die sind natürlich darauf angelegt, sehr langfristige Schwerelosigkeitsexperimente zu machen. Aber da habe ich dann natürlich auch das Problem, wenn ich für einen Zeitraum von drei Monaten hochqualitative Schwerelosigkeit will, dann wird in der Zeit auch entweder die Astronautenstoßen an die Wand erzeugen, Erschütterungen oder wieder eine Raumkapsel dockt an erzeugt, Erschütterungen oder die Bahn muss angehoben werden, ich habe wieder eine Beschleunigung. Also da wird die Qualität gestört. Unsere Schwerelosigkeitsphase ist natürlich deutlich kürzer. Also damit es hier keine Missverständnisse gibt, die liegt im Bereich von zweieinhalb Minuten bis 15 Minuten. Ist aber im Prinzip störungsfrei in dieser Zeit.
Das heißt, das ist so eine ideale Parabel, die man schön lang ziehen kann?
Das ist eine ideale Parabel, die man schön lang ziehen kann. Wie gesagt, das Längste, was geht, ist knappe Viertelstunde.
Das ist schon eine Menge.
Gut, das hängt natürlich davon ab, wie hoch man die Rakete schießt. Es gibt Raketen, die schaffen bis zu maximal 1000 bis 1500 Kilometer. Da muss man erst mal hochkommen und wieder runterfallen. Das dauert dann schon ein bisschen.
1500 Kilometer? Aber üblicherweise spielt es sich jetzt wirklich genau in diesem Bereich ab, jenseits der Ballone.
Das ist der übliche Bereich. So 250 Kilometer ist so eine Standardhöhe, die genutzt wird. Das liegt auch daran, dass die Zeit für die meisten Experimente völlig ausreichend ist.
Also dass man gar nicht höher muss?
Dass man gar nicht höher muss oder gar nicht länger schwere Losigkeitsphasen braucht.
Wo kommen jetzt diese Raketen her? Also ist das auch alles eine Eigenentwicklung?
Wo kommen diese Raketen her? Vieles, was wir benutzen, das sind... Vielleicht sollte ich mal grundsätzlich kurz auf so einen Aufbau von so einer Rakete eingehen. Es gibt ja nicht die Rakete an sich, sondern eine Rakete besteht aus mehreren Bestandteilen. Und da haben wir als ersten Bestandteil den sogenannten Motor. Das ist also mehr oder weniger diese Stahlhülle am unteren Ende der Rakete, wo der Treibstoff drin ist, oder der Treibsatz. Alles, was wir verwenden, sind Feststoffantriebe. Also keine Flüssigkeitsantriebe, wo irgendein Wasserstoff-Sauerstoff-Gemisch zusammengeführt wird. Wir verwenden ähnliches Feststoffkonzept, wie zum Beispiel in den Shuttleboostern wird es auch verwendet. Das sind Treibstoffe, besteht aus Ammonium, Perchlorat und Aluminium.
Oder halt auch bei der Ariane 5.
Bei der Ariane wird es auch verwendet.
Also das, was als erstes gestartet wird und das, was auch verbrennt bis zum Schluss, was man auch nicht aufhören lassen kann.
Das kann man auch nicht aufhören lassen. Das ist ein entscheidender Punkt. Einmal gezündet, dann ist die Sache.
An der Stelle sei auch nochmal auf unsere dritte Ausgabe verwiesen. Das mache ich ja mal gerne hier. Da ging es ja um die Raketentechnik. Da war der Fokus ganz klar auf Ariane. Da, wo sozusagen Heavy Gear vorbereitet wird. Aber das ist ja auch hier der Reiz, dass das hier alles dadurch, dass es etwas kleiner ist, und händelbarer ist, man eben auch an sehr viel mehr Schritten beteiligt ist. Während sich ja sonst die Raumfahrt auch immer dadurch auszeichnet, dass man eine extreme Kooperation und Aufteilung in kleinste Schritte hat. Und viele Leute zwar dem Projekt beitragen, aber keiner wirklich mit allem in Verbindung ist.
Das ist ja hier auf einem ganz anderen Scope. Das ist hier ein bisschen anders. Das ist natürlich auch das Schöne, weil man hier bei uns in der Abteilung im Prinzip den kompletten Entwicklungsprozess mitkriegt, von Anfang bis Ende. Aber um vielleicht noch mal kurz auf deine Frage zurückzukommen, also was wir benutzen, das sind einerseits alte Militärraketen, die ausgemustert wurden. Und zwar kriegen wir dann natürlich nur den Motor. Und mit dem Rest wollen wir auch gar nichts zu tun haben. Viele Leute denken immer, wenn die hören, Raketen ist mir tatsächlich schon passiert, wenn ich erzählt habe, wo arbeitest du jetzt mobile Raketenbasis, ja das hätte ich von dir nicht gedacht und so. Also Raketen sind nicht grundsätzlich Waffen, sollte man vielleicht immer wieder...
Klingt ja auch so ein bisschen bedrohlicher.
Ja, man liest natürlich in den Medien dann immer Iran startet Rakete, Nordkorea und so und da denken die Leute immer, um Gottes Willen, so einen Scheiß machst du da auch. Also damit nichts zu tun ist einfach nur ein Mittel, um Dinge weit weg von der Erde zu befördern, zu welchem Zweck auch immer. Und teilweise sind es auch Eigenentwicklungen von, ja wir haben da eine Kooperation mit Brasilien, die entwickeln auch eigene Raketenmotoren, können die auch bauen und das sind eigentlich so unsere zwei Hauptquellen. Aber im Prinzip, was wir machen, ist eine schöne Art und Weise der Abriss.
Aber ist das jetzt völlig, also im Sinne von ihr benutzt alte Raketen, konkret die DLR oder ihr benutzt die Designs und baut die selber?
Nein, nein, Moment, wir benutzen nur, ich hab jetzt nur von den Motoren geredet, wir benutzen nur diese Motoren. Also das ist im Endeffekt wirklich nur dieses Stahlrohr mit dem Treibsatz drin. Alles andere, die sogenannte Nutzlast zum Beispiel, die auf diesen Motor draufgebaut wird, das sind also Systeme, die die Rakete steuern, dann haben wir Systeme, die ein falschen Bergungssystem beinhalten, dann natürlich die eigentlichen Experimentsysteme, ganz obendrauf hast du eine Nasenspitze, da ist oft noch eine GPS-Antenne zum Beispiel drin, oder auch Experimente unter der Nasenspitze, das alles konstruieren wir und bauen wir. Da gibt es natürlich auch gewisse Standards, die man immer wieder verwendet, zum Beispiel auf einem bestimmten Motor kann ich nur eine Nutzlast im Wesentlichen einer bestimmten Größe bauen. Also ich kann da nicht beliebig variieren, weil ich muss ja auch auf Dinge achten wie Flugstabilität, dass es nicht auseinanderbricht bei den Belastungen beim Start und so weiter und so fort. Aber diese ganzen Dinge, um die kümmern wir uns dann.
So, das heißt, bei den Motoren bedient man sich einfach bereits existierender Systeme oder woanders gebaut wurden.
Wir tun das.
Und das heißt, dass auch der Fokus quasi auf allem anderen liegt?
Ja, wenn du so willst, ja.
Also auf dem, alles außerhalb des Motors sozusagen. Ja, jetzt hast du ja schon begonnen zu sagen, wie ist das Ding aufgebaut, wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Also, die kleinste Variante ist, glaube ich, so ein 6 Meter Dicken.
Ja, die kleinste Variante ist genau die Rakete, die für das Rexus-Projekt verwendet wird. Die ist im Durchschnitt 6, 6,5 Meter lang. Und zwar insgesamt vom einen Ende, also vom unteren Ende, wo die Düse ist, bis zur Raketenspitze. Auch dafür werden alte, ausgemusterte Militärraketen verwendet. Das ist das ehemalige Flugabwehrraketensystem Hawk. Und diese Motoren, die stammen aus den 60er Jahren und da lagern eine Menge davon in S-Range, in Kiruna. Und statt dass man die verschrottet, was auch aufwendig und teuer wär, benutzt man die zum Beispiel, um diese Studentenexperimente zu starten.
So ein amerikanisches Flugabwehrsystem. Das ist ja auch eine Form der Abrüstung.
Das ist doch eine wunderbare Form der Abrüstung, dass man alte Militär-Raketenmotoren nimmt, um dann Studentenexperimente darauf zu fliegen. Besser geht es ja gar nicht.
Und unten ist der Motor, hinten ist die Düse.
Und da drüber kommt die Nutzlast. Hinten ist die Düse, an der Düse dran sind auch noch sogenannte Fins befestigt. Das sind diese Flossen, die man klassischerweise bei jedem Bild, das man von einer Rakete vor Augen hat, sich vorstellt. Die dienen zur Stabilisierung der Flugbahn. Die dienen auch dazu, die Rakete in eine Drehung, um die Längsachse zu versetzen. Diese Drehung bewirkt auch eine Stabilisierung der Flugbahn.
Das heißt, die sind gar nicht gerade, sondern so leicht verschrägt?
Die sind ein bisschen verkantet, ja. Durch den Luftwiderstand erzeugen die eine Drehung. Bei unseren Raketen drei bis vier Hertz. Das hilft auch, die Flugbahn zu stabilisieren. Drei bis vier Mal die Sekunde rotieren die um sich selber. Zum weiteren Aufbau gibt es eine Schnittstelle zwischen dem Motor und der Nutzlast. Das ist der sogenannte Motoradapter. In diesem Motoradapter ist eine Vorrichtung, die den Motor nach Ausbrand abtrennt. Der fällt dann praktisch nach unten. Über den Motoradapter kommt dann das Fallschirmbergungssystem. Da ist also ein Fallschirm drin. Über dem Fallschirmsystem kommt das sogenannte Servicestem. Das Servicestem ist also zuständig, ja das ist quasi der Hausmeister der Rakete. Das ist also dafür da Telemetriedaten an die Bodenstation zu senden, im Zweifel auch Telekommandos zu empfangen, sofern denn welche gesendet sind. Das Servicestem kann Power liefern für die Experimente, kontrolliert den Stromfluss, kontrolliert die Timeline, sendet Signale an Experimente, sendet Signale aus, dass irgendwelche bestimmten Ereignisse eintreten sollen. Und dann über dem Servicestem kommen dann die verschiedenen Nutzlastmodule. Also so eine Rakete muss man sich so ein bisschen vorstellen, wie ja ist im Endeffekt so ein Legosystem. Man hat verschiedene Module, das sind einfach, wir nennen die Töpfe, das sind runde Aluminium, Zylinder, die haben einen, also für diese kleinste Rakete haben die einen Durchmesser von 14 Zoll, sind glaube ich 355 Millimeter, sowas. Und die Höhe kann variieren, je nach der Anforderung des Experiments, das da drin ist, wie viel Platz das braucht. Also wir haben Höhen von 120 Millimeter bis zu 300 Millimeter. Und dann kann man diese verschiedenen Töpfe, in diese Töpfe baut man die Experimente ein und dann kann man die, wir haben eher weniger naiv gesprochen, aufeinander stapeln, setzt oben die Spitze drauf, pappt unten den Motor dran und schon hat man eine flugfähige Rakete.
Und hat das eine zentrale Stromversorgung dann auch für die Experimente oder müssen die alle mit ihren eigenen Akkus daherkommen?
Das hängt natürlich auch von den Systemen ab. Bei diesen Rexus-Raketen zum Beispiel liefert das Service-System die Stromversorgung für die Experimente. Die können aber auch eigene Batterien haben.
Das heißt, jetzt kommt so die ganze Nutzlast und dann ist irgendwann die letzte drauf. Dann kommt nur noch die Spitze obendrauf und fertig.
Dann kommt die Spitze obendrauf und im Groben fertig.
Das heißt, dieses Service-Modul ist eigentlich so ein bisschen das Herz der ganzen Geschichte.
Könnte man so sagen, ja.
Du hast gesagt, man kann auch Telekommando, also man kann nicht nur davon empfangen, also nicht nur Telemetrie empfangen, sondern man kann auch was hinschicken. Was könnte diese Rakete denn überhaupt... Also normalerweise macht man das nicht. Man startet das Teil und dann ist das Flugzeug fertig.
Nein, nein, was heißt normalerweise macht man das nicht. Das hatte ich jetzt ein bisschen auf diese kleinste Rakete bezogen, für dieses Rexus-Projekt. Da haben wir es bisher noch nicht gemacht. Es wird normalerweise schon auch gemacht. Ein ganz wichtiger Punkt, für das man zum Beispiel ein Telekommandosystem braucht, ist, um die Lage-Regelung der Rakete zu steuern. Wenn also eine Rakete startet, dann durchquert sie also erstmal die Atmosphäre, befindet sich dann im mehr oder weniger luftleeren Raum, hat immer noch diese Spinnrate, dreht sich um ihre eigene Achse. Diese Spinnrate wird erstmal rausgenommen mit Hilfe eines ganz ausgefuchsten Systems. Das ist ein sogenanntes Jo-Joh-System. Da sind im Endeffekt zwei Seile mit zwei Massen an den Enden um die Rakete herumgewickelt, die festgemacht sind, dann wird die Verankerung gelöst und durch die Drehung wickeln sich die Seile nach außen ab. Das muss man sich also im Endeffekt vorstellen wie den Pirouetteneffekt bei einem Eisläufer. Wenn der die Arme anzieht, dann dreht er sich sehr schnell. Sobald er die Arme ausstreckt, dreht er sich langsamer. Das heißt, der Drehimpuls wird von ihm fortgetragen.
Das heißt, man lässt quasi die Arme frei und dann wickelt sich die Rakete selber ab?
Die Seile wickeln sich nach außen ab, dadurch wird die Drehung der Rakete langsamer. Wir können die bis auf Null runterbringen, die Drehung, und die Seile fliegen dann fort und nehmen praktisch diese Drehenergie mit. Man sagt immer ein bisschen so, es ist nicht ganz korrekt, aber es ist ein bisschen so, wie wenn man beim Eisläufer, wenn er die Arme ausgestreckt hat und sich ganz langsam dreht, die Arme abhacken würde, und dann dreht er sich auch nicht mehr schneller. Aber der Vergleich hinkt natürlich.
Ja, sehr besonders. Aber ab dem Moment ist sozusagen diese Rotation nicht mehr gewünscht. Vorher war sie wichtig, um überhaupt erst mal die Flugstabilität zu garantieren. Weil Rotationen dann entsprechend noch festigt die Flugbahn. Dann eiert das Teil nicht.
Richtig.
Aber in dem Moment, wo man dann aus der Atmosphäre raus ist, und dann will man sozusagen die Experimente starten, und dann ist es nicht mehr so gut, wenn man nicht so viel dreht.
Es ist ja ganz klar, man will Experimente unter Schwerelosigkeit machen. Und wenn sich die Rakete viermal pro Sekunde um sich selber dreht, weiß jeder, der schon mal am Karussell war, dann hat man eine enorme Fliehkraft nach außen. Und das ist ja genau das, was man eigentlich nicht haben will. Man will ja Schwerelosigkeit oder Kräftefreiheit ist ja Schwerelosigkeit letztendlich. Also auch keine Zentrifugalkraft. Und deswegen muss man diese Drehung rausnehmen. Und dann ist es so, dass die Rakete sich natürlich auch noch ziemlich viel langsamer um die anderen Achsen bewegen kann. Das heißt nicht, dass sie komplett still steht im Raum. Für manche Experimente ist aber die Anforderung, dass die Rakete komplett still steht im Raum. Und dafür kann man zum Beispiel ein Lageregelungssystem nutzen, was darauf basiert. Eine andere Wahl habe ich im kräftefreien Raum auch nicht, dass ich Gas in einer bestimmten Richtung aus der Rakete ausstoße. Und dieses Gas vermindert eine Bewegung in der entgegengesetzten Richtung. Und auf diese Art und Weise wird auch beim Special Shuttle so gemacht, wenn sich das um seine eigene Achse drehen soll und die Drehung wieder gestoppt werden soll. Auf diese Art und Weise kann ich es schaffen, die Rakete komplett in Ruhe zu versetzen. Und das muss ich natürlich auch steuern können. Dafür kann man zum Beispiel Telekommando verwenden. Telekommando müsste man auch verwenden, wenn man Experimente hat, bei denen nicht von Haus aus klar ist, wann ein bestimmtes Ereignis eintritt. Zum Beispiel ein experimenteffektives Beispiel. Man hat eine Kamera auf eine Flüssigkeit und in dem Moment, wo die Flüssigkeit blau wird, soll irgendwas anderes passieren. Jetzt wird es auf ein Videobild übertragen und ich weiß nicht, wann die Flüssigkeit blau wird. Aber wenn sie blau wird, möchte ich einen Knopf drücken und sagen, jetzt bitte die Flüssigkeit in Rotation versetzen oder was auch immer. So ungefähr. Dafür bräuchte man auch Telekommandos. Wo man es nicht braucht, ist, wenn man Experimentabläufe hat, die nach einer automatischen Zeitvorgabe oder Timeline auch genannt ablaufen.
Das heißt, dieses modulare Konzept geht sogar so weit, dass man je nach Experimentbedarf gegebenenfalls noch weitere Serviceeinheiten dazu macht. Ich meine jetzt nicht nochmal so ein Servicemodul wie das Hauptservicemodul, aber zum Beispiel diese Lageregelung, die baut man dann halt nur dann mit rein, wenn man sie auch braucht.
Wenn man sie auch braucht, natürlich. Warum soll ich eine Lageregelung mitfliegen, wenn ich keine brauche? Ist nur unnötiger Ballast. Und alles, was man bei Raketenflügen gar nicht haben will, ist ganz klar zu viel Masse. Also Hauptaugenmerk ist immer so leicht wie möglich.
Was gibt es da sonst noch so für Module, die man dann auch so reinpacken könnte?
Das ist es eigentlich im Wesentlichen.
Aber grundsätzlich ist diese Modularität auch sinnvoll, weil ja auch die Experimente unterschiedlichen Platzbedarf haben, unterschiedlich groß sind. Und man steckt sich das einfach so zusammen. Kann man das dann so beliebig lang machen?
Nein, das kann man natürlich nicht beliebig lang machen, weil das wiederum die Stabilität der Rakete beim Flug beeinflussen würde. Da gibt es schon genaue Berechnungen und Erfahrungswerte, auf welchen Motor kann ich welche Nutzlast setzen. Und wenn ich auf einen bestimmten Motor eine 100 Meter lange Nutzlast setze und das starte, dann wird es im Sekundenbruchteilen auseinanderfallen, weil es den Belastungen beim Start einfach nicht gewachsen ist. Es muss in sich schon ein stabiles System sein. Das ist klar. Ich kann es nicht beliebig anpassen.
Jetzt steht das ganze Jahr im Dienst der Experimente. Man macht das jetzt nicht nur so, weil man Raketen cool findet. Das natürlich auch, aber das Ganze hat einen bestimmten Zweck. Es soll der wissenschaftlichen Forschung dienen. Jetzt haben wir ja im Prinzip auch zwei Kontexte, über die wir hier sprechen können. Einerseits die gesamte Experimentwelt, die jetzt an dieser mobilen Raketenbasis überhaupt dranhängt. Da gibt es ja eine Vielzahl von Raketensystemen und eine Vielzahl von Experimenten und Kampagnen, die gemacht werden. Konkret wollten wir uns aber jetzt hier auf diese Rexus-Kampagne und daran auch anhängt das Bexus, das ist dann die Ballon-Variante noch konzentrieren. Aber grundsätzlich in beiden Fällen ist das Spiel dasselbe. Wissenschaftlich arbeitende Menschen, Wissenschaftler oder solche, die es werden wollen, kommen, an wen wenden die sich? Wie kommt das Ganze zusammen? Wer koordiniert diese Kampagne? Macht das die Raketenbasis auch? Oder ist man da eigentlich jetzt nur Dienstleister und die wissenschaftliche Koordination findet woanders statt? Wie arbeitet das alles?
Es kommt natürlich darauf an, was du für ein Projekt hast. Aber im Prinzip läuft es schon so, dass die Leute uns auch direkt ansprechen. Man kennt sich lange, das Ganze ist ja historisch gewachsen. Es gibt ja zum Beispiel diese Texas-Kampagnen, die praktisch die industrielle Version dieser Höhenforschung sind. Mit denen arbeiten wir seit Jahren oder Jahrzehnten inzwischen zusammen. Da sind die Abläufe einfach klar. Da gibt es Wissenschaftler, die wollen bestimmte Experimente machen. Dann wird sich zusammengesetzt mit uns. Da macht man einen Zeitplan, wann eine Kampagne stattfindet. Texas steht für technologische Experimente unter Schwerelosigkeit.
Also auch ein deutscher Begriff.
Bei diesem Studentenprojekt Rexus-Bexus, was die Abkürzung ist für Raketenexperimente für Universitätsstudenten oder eben Bexus-Ballonexperimente für Universitätsstudenten, da läuft das Ganze so. Vielleicht sollte ich ein bisschen was zum Hintergrund dieses Projektes erzählen. Also Rexus-Bexus ist ein Projekt, das das DLR in Kooperation mit SSC macht. SSC, also früher Swedish Space Corporation, heißt jetzt nur noch SSC. Basiert also auf einem bilateralen Abkommen.
War das jetzt die schwedische Raumfahrt-Agentur, oder ist es auch noch oder ist das jetzt privat?
Die Agentur, nein, die SSC ist nicht die Agentur. Die Agentur heißt SNSB, Swedish National Space Board. Das ist ungefähr parallel zu sehen, wie es gibt ja das DLR-Raumfahrt-Management früher, die DLR-Agentur, und das DLR als ausführendes Organ. Und bei den Schweden ist es ähnlich. Also der Träger des Projektes sind letztendlich die Agenturen, also die DLR-Agentur oder jetzt eben Raumfahrt-Management und SNSB. Durchgeführt wird das Ganze dann eben von DLR oder SSC. Und die Schweden haben auch noch die ESA als Kooperationspartner mit ins Boot geholt. Und da läuft das Ganze also so, dass sich Studenten aus sämtlichen ESA-Mitgliedsländern bewerben können und die Ausschreibungen werden jeweils von den Agenturen gemacht, also von DLR-Agentur und SNSB. Dann gibt es also einmal im Jahr eine Ausschreibung. Die nächste beginnt am 1. September 2012. Und dann gibt es einen Ausschreibungszeitraum, der geht ungefähr 6 bis 8 Wochen. Und dann kann man sich bewerben. Was für Studenten wendet sich das jetzt? Das wendet sich eigentlich an alle Studenten, die ein interessantes Experiment vorschlagen.
Also man muss jetzt auch nicht an einer besonderen Universität angeschlossen sein, die jetzt in irgendeiner Form in Kooperation ist?
Man muss nicht an einer besonderen Universität sein. Man sollte nur an einer Universität studieren, die eben eines der ESA-Mitgliedsländer, in einem der ESA-Mitgliedsländer behergerachtet ist. Heißt auch nicht, dass man die Staatsbürgerschaft haben muss. Aber man sollte Student an einer dieser Universitäten sein. Und wenn man einen interessanten Vorschlag hat, dann kann man den einreichen.
Das ist jetzt auch nicht auf eine bestimmte Wissenschaftskategorie beschränkt.
Das ist überhaupt nicht auf eine bestimmte Wissenschaftskategorie beschränkt. Das Spektrum, das wir schon hatten an Experimenten, geht also durch die ganze Bandbreite von Naturwissenschaft und Technik.
Also ist egal, Chemie, Biologie, Physik?
Das ist egal, aber...
Mathematiker sind wahrscheinlich nicht so vertreten.
Ich wüsste jetzt nicht, wofür man für ein mathematisches Experiment... Wenn so ein Vorschlag mal kommt, das wäre interessant. Das würde mich persönlich sehr interessieren, was man da machen kann. Also im Prinzip sind wir für alles offen. Weil du gesagt hast, Biologie, was wir nicht machen, ist, wir fliegen also nichts, was uns anschauen kann. Also wenn jemand einen Vorschlag einreicht, wie mein Hamster wollte schon immer Astronaut werden, das ist seine Chance, oder ich wollte schon immer mal sehen, ob eine Flunder bei 30-facher Erdbeschleunigung beim Start noch flacher wird, als sie eh schon ist, geht nicht.
Okay, keine Flunder, keine Hamster.
Geht nicht, keine Flunder, keine Hamster. Die Industrieversion Texas zum Beispiel, die machen das schon. Die haben mal Fische geflogen, oder schon des Öfteren Fische geflogen. Jeder Fisch hatte seine eigene kleine Kammer. Da hat man Versuche gemacht, um den Gleichgewichtssinn besser zu verstehen. Aber das ist auch eine aufwendige Geschichte. Solche Sachen machen wir nicht. Wir hatten aber schon biologische Experimente. Auf diesen Bexus-Ballonen hatten wir schon Experimente, die versucht haben, Lebensspuren in der Hochatmosphäre zu finden. Und zwar DNA-Reste oder Mikroorganismen. Da hatten wir zwei Experimente dazu.
An der Stelle ist es aber auch wirklich Höhenforschung.
Ich habe vorher selber diesen Begriff wieder verwendet. Ich habe es gemerkt, Höhenforschung, in dem Fall ist es biologische Forschung in der Höhe.
Es kommen eigentlich zwei Sachen zusammen. Einerseits diese Raketengeschichte, was konkret zugeschnitten auf ein studentisches, akademisches Publikum bzw. als Dienstleistung für diese designte Kampagnen, auf Raketenbasis, das ist Rexus. Außerdem im Rahmen desselben Programms kann man aber auch genauso gut Experimente für einen Höhenballon positionieren. Da sieht es jetzt auch vom technischen Aufbau her ganz anders aus. Das ist aber auch Teil des Programms. Aber jetzt nicht unbedingt eure Aufgabe hier der mobilen Raketenbasis, das mit zu betreiben, oder wie ist das aufgeteilt?
Das will ich so nicht sagen. Die Aufteilung geht in der Tat ein bisschen in die Richtung, dass wir uns mehr um die Raketengeschichte kümmern und die schwedische Partnerseite kümmert sich mehr um die Ballongeschichte. Das ist einfach der Tatsache geschuldet, dass es auf diesem Startplatz in Kiruna, S-Range, eine große Ballonplattform gibt, dass dort sehr oft Ballonkampagnen stattfinden und dass demzufolge auch die Schweden einfach viel mehr Erfahrung mit dem Starten von Ballonen haben. Deswegen kümmern sich die Schweden mehr um diese Ballonstarts. Aber wir sind durchaus in beiden Systemen involviert. Es gibt also Ballonsysteme, die von der Moraba entwickelt wurden. Früher hatte die Moraba auch mehr mit Ballonen zu tun. Das ist halt immer eine Sache, was gerade so gefragt ist. Auf der anderen Seite ist es auch so, dass die Schweden, die schwedische Seite des Rexus-Bexus-Projektes auch mit einem eigenen Service-System in einer Rakete beteiligt ist, das die betreuen und das die managen.
Also das greift alles ein bisschen ineinander?
Das greift alles ineinander. Das ist eine echte Kooperation. Das ist auch Bestandteil einer übergreifenden Kooperation namens Juro Launch. Das ist also wirklich eine Kooperation zwischen mobiler Raketenbasis und S-Range, die es auch Kunden erleichtert. Wir bieten im Endeffekt Flugtickets an, wo ein Kunde kommen kann, ein Experimentator, und sagt, ich möchte in Kiruna ein Experiment starten. Macht mal und dann machen wir das. Und dadurch, dass wir so eine enge Zusammenarbeit, auch eine sehr freundschaftliche Zusammenarbeit mit den Schweden haben, macht es die Sache natürlich auch einfacher für alle Beteiligten. Man kennt sich auch, wir sind relativ häufig in Kiruna und man weiß, wie da andere arbeiten.
Okay, aber Muraba ist jetzt auch nicht das einzige DLR-Institut, was jetzt an diesem Projekt beteiligt ist?
Das Rexus-Projekt oder Rexus-Bexus-Projekt selber ist DLR-seitig, die studentische Betreuung ist in Bremen aufgehängt. Also die Bremer Kollegen kümmern sich um die Betreuung der Studentenexperimente. Die Agentur kümmert sich um die Ausschreibung und auch darum, den wissenschaftlichen Output publik zu machen. Die Muraba ist mehr oder weniger zuständig für die Durchführung der Raketenstarts an sich der Kampagnen. Die S-Range in Schweden ist verantwortlich für die Durchführung der Raketen- und Ballonkampagnen, weil ja beide auf S-Range gestartet werden. Das ist im Wesentlichen die Organisation.
Vielleicht kann man das mal so ein bisschen greifbarer machen. Vielleicht erinnerst du dich noch an irgendein Projekt, was gelaufen ist, was vielleicht ganz typisch ist. Vielleicht sind sie ja auch alle typisch, das weiß ich nicht.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das ist schwierig.
Oder wir können jetzt auch hypothetisch einfach nur was herausgreifen angenommen, es gibt jetzt in irgendeiner Disziplin ein, wird ja in der Regel nicht nur ein Student sein, sondern eher eine Gruppe von Studenten.
Nein, das sind also Gruppen von Studenten. Die typische Teamgröße ist vier bis acht Leute. Wir hatten auch schon Teams dabei, das war ein Team von der TU München, glaube ich. Die hatten dann so um die 30 Leute oder so was. Also das ist aber schon groß. Also es macht natürlich keinen Sinn, wenn sich einer alleine bewirbt, weil ich schätze, alleine kann man so ein Projekt eigentlich nicht stemmen. Das müsste dann schon was ganz Triviales sein.
Oder ein totaler Überflieger.
Ja, oder ein totaler Überflieger. Meistens haben diese Experimente, aus welchem Bereich sie jetzt immer sind, bringen mehrere Herausforderungen mit sich. Zum einen ist es natürlich die mechanische Seite, dann hast du eine elektrische Seite, dann hast du eine Software-Seite, dann hast du die wissenschaftliche Seite, dass überhaupt jemand eine gewitzte wissenschaftliche Idee hat und sich auch überlegt, was soll eigentlich bei rumkommen. Will ich mal eine Veröffentlichung drüber schreiben? Deswegen sag ich mal, das ideale Team besteht aus einem Mechanikingenieur, einem Elektronikingenieur, einem Softwareingenieur, einem Projektmanager. Auch ein sehr wichtiger Aspekt eines Rexus-Bexus-Teams, dass man wirklich lernt, sich zu organisieren, dass man Teammanagement macht, dass man Projektmanagement macht, dass man es auch schafft, die Zeitpläne einzuhalten. Also die Durchschnittsgrößen sind so vier bis acht Leute.
Die sich selbst irgendwie interdisziplinär aufstellen müssen.
Die sich selbst eigentlich aufstellen müssen, ja.
Weil die müssen ja jetzt auch, dass man den Begriff Dienstleistung nicht falsch versteht. Es geht nicht so darum, die wollen ein Experiment machen, dann kommt man ja her und dann wird das hier gebaut. Sondern es geht eigentlich darum, die Nutzlast muss von dieser Studentengruppe im Prinzip selbst gebaut werden.
So ist es. Zumindest die Experimente für die Nutzlast müssen von den Studenten selbst gebaut werden. Die werden auch von den Studenten selbst mit unserer Unterstützung in diese Modultöpfe integriert.
Also den Topf, den gibt es sozusagen, der wird gestellt.
Der Topf wird gestellt.
Aber alles, was da drin ist, muss man selber...
Der ist ja auch standardisiert.... standardisiert. Alles, was da drin ist, muss man mehr oder weniger sich selber ausdenken. Selber zusammenbauen ist selber für alles verantwortlich. Wir schauen natürlich über die ganze Sache drüber, ob das mit den Schnittstellen zum Rest der Rakete passt, dass nichts Gefährliches passiert, dass da keine seltsamen Sachen auftreten.
Im Prinzip so die Anforderungen, die als auch an Wissenschaftler gestellt werden, die in einer großen Mission ein Experiment machen, aber eben alles in einem kleineren Rahmen, aber trotzdem vollständig.
Es ist in einem kleineren Rahmen, aber trotzdem vollständig. Es ist oft gesagt ein Low-Budget-Projekt. Ich mag den Begriff nicht so gern. Es ist natürlich vom finanziellen Her deutlich billiger als aufwendige Industrieprojekte. Aber es ist wirklich alles drin. Man macht den kompletten Zyklus eines Raumfahrtprojektes durch. Vielleicht sollte ich noch dazu sagen, die Projektstruktur sieht so aus, dass es im Jahr 2 Raketen und 2 Ballone zu starten ist. Wobei man im Schnitt sagen kann, hat man pro Ballon und pro Rakete ungefähr Platz für 5 Experimente. Das heißt, wir können im Jahr 20 Experimente fliegen. Ist nicht immer der Fall, dass genau 5 drauf sind. Das hängt natürlich von der Größe der Experimente ab, vielleicht auch von der Komplexität. Dann ist auch immer die Frage, hat man mehr Experimente für Ballone, hat man mehr Experimente für Raketen. Aber so ist eine gute Richtlinie. 5 pro Rakete, 5 pro Ballon. Ich hatte vorher erwähnt, die Ausschreibung findet im September statt. Die Laufzeit eines typischen Rexus-Bexus-Projektes liegt zwischen ein und eineinhalb Jahren. Das heißt, wenn der Auswahl-Workshop stattgefunden hat, das wird dann meistens im Dezember findet dann ein Workshop statt, bei dem die eingereichten Vorschläge die angenommen werden, bei dem die...
Also man muss erst mal abklopfen, ist das überhaupt ein sinnvolles Experiment?
Richtig, da findet ein Workshop statt, da stellen die...
Macht die Gruppe den Eindruck, dass sie das auch schaffen kann. Vielleicht rollen wir das mal von der anderen Seite aus. Wenn ich jetzt so, ich bin jetzt Student, und ich bin in irgendeiner Disziplin und habe eine tolle Idee, was man mal im Rahmen einer solchen Geschichte machen könnte. Ich suche mir irgendwie meine Crew zusammen.
Genau, dann suchst du dir eine Crew zusammen, du liest die Ausschreibung, dann gibt es auch ein Formular, das man praktisch ausfüllen muss, wo im Groben drin steht, was wollt ihr eigentlich machen, wie viele Leute seid ihr, warum glaubt ihr, dass ihr das schafft, warum glaubt ihr, dass ihr auf eine Rakete oder auf einen Ballon richtig ausprobiert seid.
Hast du mal ein Beispiel für so ein typisches Experiment oder vielleicht auch ein untypisches, irgendwas, was dir besonders in Erinnerung geblieben ist?
Ja gut, wir hatten Experimente aus allen möglichen Bereichen, um eins rauszugreifen. Eins, was mir jetzt zum Beispiel gerade einfällt, spontan. Das ist ein Experiment, das hieß Real Smart. Und zwar steht Real für das englische Wort für Angel. Und die hatten also, ist eigentlich eine ganz pfiffige Idee gewesen. Das war ein Ballonexperiment. Und die haben folgende Idee gehabt, nämlich selber wieder mithilfe eines Ballonfluges, wofür ein Ballonflug ja eigentlich nicht geeignet ist, wieder in dem Fall nicht Mikro-Gravitation, aber Milligravitation zu erzeugen, indem sie von einem Ballon eine Kapsel herunterfallen lassen. Und wenn etwas herunterfällt, das ist das selbe Prinzip wie beim Fallturm in Bremen, dann hast du auch für einige Sekunden Sperelosigkeit. Ja, Sperelosigkeit. Nennen wir es Milligravitation. Vielleicht auch nur Centigravitation könnte man sagen.
Also nicht mehr ganz so viel G.
Nicht mehr ganz so viel G. Und die haben da also einen Aufbau gemacht, den sie auf den Ballon draufgebaut haben und haben also wirklich eine ganz normale Angel genommen, mit einer Angelschnur, haben da eben ihren Drop-Body dran gehängt und haben den dann fallen gelassen. Und das war also, fand ich, ein sehr abgefahrenen Experimentvorschlag. Tatsächlich gibt es jetzt auch Ideen, das professioneller zu machen, dass man einfach Sachen vom Ballon fallen lässt. Weil oft auch diese Art der Schwerelosigkeit und diese Dauer der Schwerelosigkeit für viele Experimente schon ausreichend ist. Und weil es ja eigentlich vielleicht noch billiger oder unaufwendiger ist als als einen Raketenstart, dass man das von dem Ballon macht.
Wie hoch fliegen die Ballone?
Die Ballone fliegen bis zu 30 Kilometer hoch. Die Zeitdauer eines Bexus-Ballonfluges liegt bei vier Stunden vielleicht. Hängt auch mal davon ab, was für Experimente drauf sind. Aber vier Stunden ist ein guter Richtwert. Vier, fünf Stunden. Und fliegt Richtung Finnland von Esrange aus. Aufgrund der Windrichtung. Und ist dann so 300 bis 400 Kilometer weg vom Ausgangsort. Die Ballongondel, an der die Experimente dranhängen, die wird dann vom Ballon abgetrennt. Fällt dann auch nach unten, öffnet sich aber ein Fallschirm. Und dann geht die ganz normal an den Fallschirm runter, wie auch eine Raketennutzlast auch an den Fallschirm runtergeht. Das heißt, es wird nicht nur hochgeschickt, sondern es wird auch im Realfall wieder zurückgeholt? Es wird alles wieder zurückgeholt, es wird alles wieder geborgen. Man hat sofort Zugang zu den Experimenten, kann auch sofort weitere Datenauswertungen machen. Bei Raketenflügen ist das Ganze sogar noch schneller. Da geht es teilweise bis in einer Stunde nach dem Start, kommen die Experimente teilweise schon wieder zurück.
Man muss ja erstmal da hinfahren, wo sie runtergekommen sind, weil die fliegen ja auch relativ weit, wenn sie mal so 200 km hoch waren.
Na gut, die Höhe hat ja nichts mit der Weite zu tun. Ich könnte theoretisch auch was senkrecht in die Höhe schmeißen, dann kommt es da wieder runter, wo ich es hochgeschmissen habe, dann brauche ich gar nicht weit gehen, um es zu holen. Aber um zum Punkt zu kommen, die S-Range, die hat ein sogenanntes Impengebiet. Das ist also ein Gebiet, in dem es erlaubt ist, dass diese Raketen aufschlagen dürfen. Die normale Flugweite einer solchen Rakete liegt zwischen 40 und 70 km. Die Rexus-Raketen fliegen 40 km weit weg. Die Höhe ist maximal 100 km. Das ist also schon eher eine schmale Parabel. Diese 40 km sind mit einem Helikopter, den man zur Bergung benutzt, relativ schnell überwunden. Die Kunst ist dabei, genau die Nutzlast zu finden. Da sind Sender drin, sogenannte Beacon-Sender, mit Hilfe derer man die Nutzlast lokalisieren kann. Man hat auch einen GPS-Sender drin. Man empfängt auch Telemetriedaten. Die Telemetriestation kann die Nutzlast tracken. Das bricht aber irgendwann ab. Aufgrund der Horizontgrümmung der Erde kann ich nicht bis ganz zum Boden tracken. Man hat aber eine ganz gute Idee, wo der Einschlagspunkt ist und kann damit im Helikopter hinfliegen. Da wir meistens im Winter starten und der Fallschirm orange ist und der Boden weiß ist, sieht man das dann auch ganz gut eigentlich schon aus der Entfernung, wo das Ganze liegt.
Jetzt war man ja so ein bisschen abgekommen, das Ganze aus der Studentenperspektive zu betrachten, wie das denn jetzt so abläuft. Das war jetzt so ein Beispiel für eine Bexus-Geschichte. Vielleicht auch noch mal so ein Beispiel für die Rexus, für die Rakete, was da so runtergekommen ist.
Also bei der Rakete, ja, zum Beispiel bei einer. Was momentan ganz gern gemacht wird, das haben wir jetzt für die nächsten Raketen. Rexus 13 und 14 sind an der Reihe. Nächstes Jahr im Frühjahr. Was ganz gern gemacht wird, sind zurzeit Experimente, die irgendwas von der Rakete abwerfen. Das heißt also, in dem Modul sind kleine Körper eingebaut, sogenannte Free Falling Units. Da sind dann irgendwelche Sensoren drin. Dann hast du ein sogenanntes Hatch, eine Luke am Modul. Und wenn, also nach dem Motor ausbrannt, wenn die Experimentierphase dann beginnt, wird dieses Hatch abgeworfen. Und diese Free Falling Unit wird nach außen befördert. Die sind meistens mit einer, hängen an einer gespannten Feder dran. Und diese Feder wird dann released und schießt das Ganze raus. Und dann fallen diese Free Falling Units, die fallen dann auch wieder mit runter zur Erde, machen in verschiedenen Höhen, verschiedene Messungen zu elektrischen Feldern, Magnetfeldern, was auch immer das Experiment machen will. Und es ist teilweise wirklich anspruchsvoll, was die Leute da machen. Der Anspruch geht inzwischen dahin, die ganzen Teile sicher zu landen mit kleinen Fallschirmsystemen und auch wieder zu bergen und zurückzuholen.
So kleine Mininutzlasten, die dann nochmal abgespaltet werden.
Das sind dann so kleine Mininutzlasten. Und das andere ist, was zum Beispiel sehr beliebt ist momentan, ist irgendwelche Strukturen, die sich entfalten. Zum Beispiel aufblasbare Segel. Letztens hatten wir ein Experiment bei der letzten Rexus. Das war eine irische Gruppe. Im Endeffekt sind es Technologie-Demonstratoren. Die hatten unter der Nasenspitze eine Vorrichtung montiert, die ein Netz entfalten sollte. Und zwar noch durch die Drehung der Rakete. Ich hatte vorher erwähnt, wenn die Rakete startet, dann nimmt die eine Drehung auf von bis zu 4 Hertz. Diese Drehung kann man nutzen, um durch die Zentrifugalkraft ein Netz zu entfalten. Das haben die gemacht. Dieses Experiment musste stattfinden, bevor die Drehrate aus der Rakete rausgenommen wurde. Das war ein Experiment unter der Nasenspitze. Dazu wurde die Nasenspitze abgesprengt. Dann hat sich dieses Netz entfaltet. Dieses sich entfaltende Netz war auch auf einem Körper, der von der Raketenspitze abgestoßen wurde. Da waren auch Kameras drin. Sowohl an der Rakete selber, die dann filmen sollten, wie dieses Modul mit dem sich entfaltenden Netz wegfliegt. Und eine Kamera auch in dem Modul, die wieder zurückfilmt zur Rakete. Da war der Anspruch, dass man es wieder findet. Sie haben es bis jetzt nicht gefunden. Im August will dieses Team eine Expedition nach Kiruna machen und dort durch die Wälder streifen und versuchen also dieses entfaltete Netz zu finden. Sie haben ein paar Bilder gemacht, wo man sieht, dass dieses Netz sich tatsächlich entfaltet hat. Aber was eben nicht mehr funktioniert hat, war das eingebaute GPS, welches dann den Lande oder Einschlagsort angeben sollte. Das ist ein relativ kleines Teil. Dieses Netz hat einen Durchmesser von 50 cm. Das findest du dann natürlich nicht so einfach. Aber es ist eine extrem anspruchsvolle Sache.
Es scheint auch eine Menge Bandbreite zu geben. Sowohl wissenschaftliche Experimente als solche, als auch konkrete Dinge, die man für Raumflüge benutzen kann. Wie groß ist der Anteil von Studenten, die jetzt so explizit in Richtung Raumfahrt hin, ohnehin studieren? Und wie viel ist so Wissenschaftler, die jetzt an der Stelle zwar die Raumfahrt nutzen, aber an sich in eine ganz andere Richtung marschieren?
Naja, das überschneidet sich natürlich oft auch ein bisschen. Aber ich würde fast sagen 50-50. Also an, sagen wir mal, nicht an Technologiedemonstratoren für die Raumfahrt, sondern an, ich nenne es mal in Anführungszeichen, echten wissenschaftlichen Anwendungen hatten wir zum Beispiel ein Experiment letztes Jahr, das hat untersucht, wie sich kleine Sedimentation oder wie sich kleine Sedimente zusammenfinden. Unter Schwerelosigkeit in einer vibrierenden Kammer, da ging es eigentlich darum, Planetenentstehungen oder Entstehungen von Planetismalen besser zu verstehen. Wie klumpen die zusammen unter Schwerelosigkeit, wenn sie stößend ausgesetzt sind? Das ist ja letztendlich das, wie man sich die Planetenbildung vorstellt. Die hatten ihre kleinen Materialproben in einer Kammer, haben die Wände vibrieren lassen und dann Filme gemacht und diese Filme ausgewertet und das Klumpungsverhalten untersucht. Dann gibt es natürlich auch Sachen, die, wie ich gesagt habe, überschneidet sich. Wir hatten auch Experimente. Es gibt eigentlich immer so bestimmte Evolutionslinien, kann man fast sagen, wenn man das durch die letzten Jahre verfolgt. Eine Linie ist eben dieses, wir werfen irgendwas aus der Rakete raus, was möglichst auch mit einem eigenen Fallschirm landen soll. Eine andere Evolutionslinie ist dieses, wir entfalten irgendeine Struktur. Da hatten wir mal eine sehr abgefahrene Experimentidee. Das war ein Experiment, die haben Verbund Faserwerkstoffe in ihrer Kammer mitgeschossen, wo diese Harzmatrix noch nicht ausgehärtet war. Das ist also noch quasi flüssig gewesen. Haben das dann unter Mikro- oder Miligravitation in eine Struktur gebracht und dann ausgehärtet, indem sie es mit Ultraviolettlicht bestrahlt haben. Wie auch immer das im Detail dann funktioniert. Das ist schon ziemlich abgefahren in der Materialwissenschaft. Es hatte natürlich aber auch den Hintergrund, dass man sagt, wenn man Strukturen im Weltall aufbauen will, Raumstationen, Solarpanel oder was auch immer, dann nimmt man meistens Stangen mit oder Gelenke, die schon fix sind, mit diesen Verbundfaserstoffen, die man dann erst in eine Struktur bringt. Das ist einfach platzsparend. Man baut die erst in der Schwerelosigkeit richtig auf. Man baut sich seine eigene Fabrik auf. Es gibt da wirklich die abgefahrensten Ideen. Dann hatten wir Experimente zu Verhalten von Flüssigkeiten in der Schwerelosigkeit. Da war die Grundidee dahinter, wenn man auf lange interplanetare Reisen geht und verschiedene Treibstofftanks mitnimmt, dann muss man ja auch umfüllen. Wie ist so das Umfüllverhalten von Flüssigkeiten unter Mikro-G-Bedingungen? Die Bandbreite ist sehr groß. Das ist einerseits Grundlagenphysik, Verhalten von Flüssigkeiten in Schwerelosigkeit. Andererseits hat es auch den Hintergrund technischer Anwendungen in der Raumfahrt. Dann haben wir, um es abzurunden, Atmosphärenphysik, was dann viel auf Bexus-Ballonen gemacht wird. Dann haben wir Navigationsexperimente, Technikexperimente, da hatten wir ein Team, die haben ihre eigene Telemetrieantenne gebaut und haben dann auf eigene Faust die Rakete mitgetrackt. Und so weiter und so fort. Die Bandbreite ist unerschöpflich.
Ja gut, angenommen, ich hab jetzt auch so eine tolle Idee. Und meine Mitschulenten finden den Plan auch prima, sich mal auf so etwas einzulassen. Ich denke mal, das ist auch was Tolles, oder? Man hat sozusagen die Möglichkeit, einmal an einer richtigen Raumfahrtmission eigentlich teilzunehmen, wie es schon angedeutet, so im Kleinen, aber eben mit vergleichbaren Anforderungen, die man aber noch mit einem sehr viel kleineren Team, zwar auch mit Druck, aber eben nicht mit ganz so hohen... Na gut, die Ansprüche sind wahrscheinlich trotzdem hoch, aber es hängt nicht so viel dran. Es ist überschaubar. Jetzt, sagst du ja, muss man sich erstmal bewerben, klar, Formular ausfüllen, erstmal ziemlich klar sagen, das ist das, was wir tun wollen, das ist das, was wir denken, was wir bauen werden. Und dann reicht man das ein bis zu einem bestimmten Stichtag und wenn es gut läuft, wird man da schon ausgewählt und muss das dann erstmal vorstellen in so einer Workshop-Session. Hab ich das richtig verstanden?
Es gibt diese Ausschreibung, dann reicht man seine Bewerbung ein, dann gibt es diesen Auswahl-Workshop, wo man sich praktisch vorstellt.
Das macht dann aber auch jeder, der sich beworben hat.
Nein, das macht nicht jeder. Wir versuchen natürlich so viele wie möglich zu dem Auswahl-Workshop zuzulassen. Aber wie gesagt, wenn einer kommt und sagt, mein Hase will Astronaut werden, dann ist das schon mal.
Es wird schon mal gesiebt, wenn auch noch nicht ganz klar nach wissenschaftlichen Kriterien, sondern es wird sozusagen das Offensichtliche beiseite gefliegt.
Das ist das Erste, was man macht auf dem Auswahl-Workshop. Das sind dann wissenschaftliche Experten. Und da wird dann schon auch nach dem wissenschaftlichen Mehrwert geschaut, natürlich nach der Machbarkeit. Das findet auch hier in Oberpfaffenhofen statt? Nein, das findet nicht in Oberpfaffenhofen statt. Wie gesagt, das findet auch nicht in Bremen statt, sondern das macht die Agentur, das findet in Bonn statt.
DLR-Rompert-Agentur.
Genau. Zumindest für die DLR-Experimente, das heißt also für Experimente, die sich aus Deutschland bewerben, für die Experimente, die von der schwedischen ESA-Seite sind, also sprich aus den anderen europäischen Staaten kommen, würde der Auswahl-Workshop dann in Estec stattfinden. Das ist ein ESA-Zentrum in Holland, Nordwijk. Ja, und dann wird im Dezember bekanntgegeben, welche Experimente angenommen sind. Und dann geht eigentlich der ganze Prozess los. Was dann als erstes folgt, ist nach zwei Monaten ungefähr ein sogenanntes Preliminary Design Review, wie man es auch in anderen Raumfahrtprojekten hat. Das heißt, da wird zum ersten Mal das Design vor einer Expertenrunde vorgestellt. Also man präsentiert da das Experiment mit elektronischen Schaltplänen, mit CAD-Zeichnungen, mit einer Beschreibung.
Wie viel Zeit war jetzt zwischen diesem Beschluss, dass man rankommt und bis man dieses Preliminary...
Zwei Monate ungefähr.
Zwei Monate.
Ungefähr, ja.
Das heißt, im Idealfall hat man sich schon eine Menge Gedanken darum gemacht und fängt nicht erst dann an, wenn man einen Zuschlag hat.
Ja, wäre, ist natürlich hilfreich, also ja. Das kann aber auch vergebliche Lebensmöglichkeiten sein. Man hat, ja, es ist natürlich so, also...
Das klingt jetzt sehr knapp, zwei Monate.
Ja, es ist ja nur, was heißt nur, es ist ja nur ein Preliminary Design. Man muss seine Ideen erstmal... Ja, nicht die Idee, aber schon ausgearbeitetes Konzept. Wie stelle ich mir das vor? Also ich muss dann schon einen Plan haben, wie baue ich das in das Modul ein? Muss mir überlegt haben, wie passt es da rein? Wie ordne ich die einzelnen Elemente meines Experiments an, dass das Ganze funktioniert, dass es aber auch zu den Schnittstellen der Rakete passt, wo platziere ich zum Beispiel eine Kamera, wenn ich eine haben will, wo platziere ich meinen Motor, was auch immer, ja. Und dieses Preliminary Design Review, das verbinden wir auch mit einer sogenannten Studententrainingswoche. Die findet abwechselnd im zweijährlichen Turnus in Esrange oder hier in Oberpfaffenhofen statt. Wird also nächstes Jahr wieder von der mobilen Raketenbasis hier ausgerichtet. Und in dieser Trainingswoche kriegen die Studenten ja sozusagen Vorlesungen und Übungen über alle Aspekte der Raketen- und Ballontechnik und zum Beispiel Vorlesungen über mechanische Integration, über was habe ich zu beachten, wenn ich ein Elektronik-Experiment designen will für die Rakete. Was habe ich zu beachten, wenn ich ein Experiment auf einem Ballon fliege, weil ich bin ja da Vakuum ausgesetzt, ich bin besonderen Temperaturen ausgesetzt. Dann gibt es Vorlesungen über Atmosphären, Physik, über GPS-Technik, je nachdem was halt gerade interessant ist und für was wir Experten kriegen. Und der nächste Schritt ist dann nach diesem preliminary design review, das Experiment quasi zu überarbeiten, gemäß den Maßgaben der Experten. Und dann kommt als nächster Schritt das critical design review, was jetzt im Moment hier gerade in Oberpfaffenhofen stattfindet. Und bei dem critical design review sollte dann alles umgesetzt sein, was beim preliminary design review, ich will nicht sagen bemängelt, aber angemerkt wurde, was man zu verändern und zu bessern hat. Na ja, wie viel Zeit hat man, sagen wir mal so. Die Trainingswoche ist zum Beispiel Ende Februar, Anfang März und jetzt haben wir Anfang Juli, das heißt wir haben März, April, Mai, Juni vier Monate ungefähr Zeit. Und das critical design review, da muss dann schon alles ziemlich genau passen, weil danach fängt man dann eigentlich im Allgemeinen auch an, wirklich die Hardware zu bauen.
Aber so vom Ablauf her sind die beiden Sachen schon vergleichbar?
Die beiden Reviews? Vom Review selber her ja, allerdings ist das critical design review nicht mit so einer Trainingswoche gekoppelt, sondern da kommen die Teams tatsächlich nur für die eineinhalb, zwei Stunden, wo sie ihr Review haben. Gut, es gibt da noch ein, zwei Vorlesungen, wo auch besprochen wird, wie baut man die Rakete zusammen, also mit wie baut man sie zusammen, meine ich, welches Experiment, muss man sich auch immer überlegen, kommt an welche Position in der Rakete, damit sich die Sachen auch nicht gegenseitig blockieren, damit es auch die Funktionsfähigkeit unserer Raketensysteme nicht beeinträchtigt. Das sind also alles Dinge, die man beachten muss, auch wie dann die Verkabelung innen läuft, dass sich das nicht gegenseitig stört. Wir hatten jetzt zum Beispiel ein Experiment, das ist ganz interessant. Die wollen Außenanbauten an die Rakete machen, und zwar zwei Staurohre von ungefähr 25 Zentimeter Länge, um atmosphärische Messungen zu machen. Und jetzt ist zum Beispiel eine Sache, die man beachten muss, ist unser Service-System, das hat auch Antennen außen dran und ursprünglich wollte dieses Modul über dem Service-System sitzen und das ist aber zum Beispiel nicht möglich, weil diese Staurohre und die Antennen, das würde sich also gegenseitig einfach blockieren, bzw. das würde die Antennenwirksamkeit stören. Nur als Beispiel mal, was man alles so beachten muss.
Es geht auch um die Constraints. Auf der einen Seite das, was man sich vorstellt, wie das eigentlich geht und den experimentellen Anforderungen, aber auf der anderen Seite dann eben auch die wirklichen Anforderungen des Flugs, der Sicherheit des Flugs, des Betriebs. Und an der Stelle bringt dann die Experten von hier Wissen ein. Und das Ganze ist so eine kritische Diskussion, sag ich mal. Ich hatte vorhin kurz die Gelegenheit, in eine kleine Session kurz mit rein zu schauen. Also die Session war länger, ich war nicht so lange dabei, aber es war eben genau dieses Critical Design Review, sprich genau jetzt heute, befindet sich eben die Vorarbeit für die anstehende Kampagne, die dann im Oktober abläuft, September, Oktober.
Nein, also nochmal ganz kurz auf diesen Zeitablauf zurückzukommen. Grundsätzlich ist es so, für ein Bexus-Experiment ist die Laufzeit ein Jahr. Das heißt, man hat die Ausschreibung, ist ja im September. Im Prinzip ist die Laufzeit ab dem Auswahl-Workshop sogar ein bisschen kürzer. Und die Bexus-Kampagnen starten normalerweise im Oktober. Das heißt, da hat man also maximal, eigentlich nicht ganz ein Jahr, 10 Monate, 11 Monate Zeit. Bei Rexus, bei den Raketenexperimenten ist die Zeitspanne ein bisschen länger. Da ist der Start erst im, ja, es hängt immer ein bisschen davon ab, was sonst noch so ansteht, aber Februar, März, sag ich mal, des darauf folgenden Jahres. Dann hat man also fast eineinhalb Jahre Zeit.
Aber war das jetzt eine Bexus oder eine Rexus?
Und dieses CD-R, wo du vorher drin gesessen bist, das war ein CD-R für Rexus. Das ist aber für Rexus, was nächstes Jahr im Februar, März fliegen wird. Das ist nicht kurz vor Schluss. Die CD-Rs, die Critical Design Reviews für Bexus, was jetzt Ende September, Oktober fliegt, die waren schon ein bisschen früher, die waren im Mai.
Okay, aber ich wollte noch mal so ein bisschen auf diesen Prozess und den Eindruck, den ich jetzt hatte als subjektiver Eindruck eines Außenstehenden. Man muss sich das vorstellen, so ein großer Raum, dann halt das Team. In dem Fall war es, glaube ich, ein achtköpfiges Studententeam.
Das waren ziemlich viele, da waren alle acht auch mit dabei. Es ist natürlich auch nicht so, dass immer alle zu jedem Review anwesend sind, aber die, sagen wir mal, wichtigsten sollten halt da sein oder die Leute sollten wissen, was sie zu sagen haben.
Die wollten auf jeden Fall alle dabei sein.
Die wollten auf jeden Fall alle dabei sein. Ist natürlich auch immer eine Sache, vielleicht auch ein wichtiger Punkt, den ich nebenbei mal erwähnen möchte, doch wir können nicht eine unbegrenzte Anzahl von Studenten sponsern. Also es ist ja so, wenn man für dieses Rexus-Bexus-Projekt angenommen wird, dann kriegt man ja jede Menge gesponsert. Wir können vier Studenten pro Team sponsern. Und das heißt, dass wir für vier Studenten die Reisen bezahlen, zum Beispiel zu diesen Preliminary Design Reviews, zu den Critical Design Reviews, was sonst noch an Reisen ansteht. Wir haben zum Beispiel auch noch eine, gut, kommen wir wahrscheinlich nachher noch drauf, eine Scientific Payload Integration Week in Bremen. Und dann natürlich am allerwichtigsten, wovon wir noch am wenigsten eigentlich gesprochen haben, die Kampagne selber, die in Esrange stattfindet. Und das können wir für vier Studenten sponsern. Es ist auch so, dass wir für ein Experimentteam auf DLR-Seite Teile, also Bauteile finanzieren können oder auch Fertigungen, die in Werkstätten zum Beispiel gemacht werden muss.
Also wer zahlt diese Kampagne letztlich? Also wer zahlt diesen ganzen Prozess?
Wer? Ja gut, letztlich zahlt es natürlich der Steuerzahler. Das sind natürlich Gelder, die von DLR und SSC für dieses Projekt bereitgestellt werden. Ich meine, das ist ein internes DLR-Projekt und dafür haben wir ein bestimmtes Budget.
Aber es ist jetzt sozusagen, DLR und SSC gemeinsam finanzieren das für die Studenten.
Richtig, so ist es. Also es kommen keine Drittmittel rein oder keine Industriezuwendungen.
Das wär meine Frage gewesen.
Nein, nein, das ist ein reines DLR-Projekt. Und wie gesagt, wir haben natürlich eine Grenze. Und vier Studenten können wir sponsern. Alle anderen Studenten, die mehr in einem Team sind, ja, da muss man sich das dann aufteilen. Oder wir hatten auch schon, zum Beispiel dieses eine große Team war es, glaube ich, mit den 30 Leuten, die hatten dann, ich glaube, Postkarten waren es im Bündel, Postkarten mitgeflogen und haben die dann für 1 Euro verkauft und haben von diesem Erlös, oder haben dieses Geld auch benutzt, um ihre restlichen Teammitglieder zu finanzieren und haben den Restbetrag dann natürlich fair unter sich aufgeteilt.
Postkarten, die da mitgeflogen sind, oder was?
Soweit ich weiß, waren das Postkarten, die da mitgeflogen sind, klar, sonst braucht man die natürlich nicht für 1 Euro verkaufen, aber nach dem Motto, diese Postkarte war im Weltraum.
Okay, nicht schlecht. Ist ja ein recht überschaubares Porto eigentlich noch, für einen Weltraumflug.
Doch, immerhin fast 100 Kilometer erreicht.
Okay, vielleicht nochmal zurück zu diesem Review. Also wenn man jetzt so eine Gruppe bildet, man ist schon so weit, dass man angenommen worden ist, man hat dann hart 2 Monate gearbeitet, stellt dann in diesem Review seinen Design vor und dann eben 4 Monate später ein weiteres Mal stellt man dann eben auch seine konkrete technische Lösung und Dokumentation vor. So genau wollen wir es bauen. Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht ist zu dem Zeitpunkt auch schon was gebaut.
Teilweise sind auch Sachen schon gebaut, ja.
Und dann sitzt man da halt so als Truppe umringt von nochmal gefühlte dreifachen Menge an Experten. Schon so eine Situation, die glaube ich ganz gut Respekt einflößt.
Es ist natürlich eine Herausforderung für die Studenten auch. Klar, man will ja auch dieses Projekt durchziehen und sieht sich jetzt eben der Situation ausgesetzt, ich muss wirklich vor einem Expertenkomitee jetzt darstellen, warum ist meine Sache sinnvoll, warum funktioniert es, warum wird nichts schiefgehen und muss sich diesen Fragen eben stellen. Wenn ein Experte auch fragt zum Beispiel, woher seid ihr euch so sicher, dass euer Ding nicht beim Start auseinanderfällt. Natürlich haben die das vorher in der Trainingswoche zum Beispiel auch schon mitgekriegt und ganz klar ist, bei einem Raketenstart zum Beispiel hat man ein Vibrationsspektrum, was nicht ohne ist und deswegen muss man natürlich auch bei der Konstruktion bestimmte Sachen beachten. Man darf zum Beispiel bei einer elektrischen Konstruktion sollte man keine Bananenstecker verwenden, weil die fliegen sofort in alle Richtungen raus, sondern es muss schon ein kompaktes Design sein, was diesen Belastungen angepasst ist. Das erzählt man natürlich den Studenten und dann überlegen die sich da was. Ganz wichtig ist, sie müssen sich auch überlegen, welche Tests machen wir. Es gibt zum Beispiel auch diese Vibrationstest. Da stellt man das Experiment auf einen sogenannten Shaker. Das ist eigentlich nichts anderes als ein großes Mikrofon, was ein gewisses Frequenzspektrum durchläuft. Dann schaut man mal, wie sich das so verhält. Wie kommt ein Mikrofon auf den Lautsprecher an?
Um Vibrationen zu erzeugen?
Ja, das erzeugt die Vibrationen. Lautsprecher mein ich natürlich. Lautsprecher, ja. In dem Fall Lautsprecher, richtig. Dann stellt man das Experiment drauf und dann durchläuft ein gewisses vorgegebenes Schwingungsspektrum, was dem einer Rakete mehr oder weniger entspricht. Dann schaut man mal, was passiert. Da kann es schon mal passieren, dass eine Schraube einfach mal raus kaputtiert wird. Diese Tests machen die Studenten danach auch. Und dann fragt man sie eben auch, habt ihr diese Tests wirklich geplant, habt ihr alles bedacht? Und was macht ihr, wenn der Test schiefgeht? Wie würdet ihr dann euer Design noch ändern? Plan B quasi und so weiter. Und man muss da schon also am Ende klarstellen, okay. Man muss im Endeffekt das Komitee davon überzeugen oder das Panel, unser Experiment wird's machen.
Das funktioniert.
Das wird funktionieren.
Ich fand die Atmosphäre sehr interessant aus verschiedenen Gründen. Auf der einen Seite hat man diese Anspannung in der Studentengruppe. Das war einfach fühlbar. Alle waren extrem konzentriert.
Es ist eine Prüfungssituation.
Genau, so ein bisschen. Man wird jetzt abgefragt und alle hofften die ganze Zeit, hoffentlich haben wir nichts vergessen. Was kommt als nächstes?
Es ist natürlich auch respekt-einflösend. Die Studenten kommen hier an. Du bist hier im Institut für Raumflugbetrieb. Hier sitzen zehn Experten gegenüber. Du weißt ganz genau, das sind alles Fachleute. Die haben es drauf und die zerlegen uns jetzt. Natürlich ist nicht wirklich die Absicht, die Studenten zu zerlegen. Aber es ist absolut eine kooperative Atmosphäre. Es ist wie eine Prüfungssituation, aber es ist natürlich keine Prüfungssituation. Unser Ziel ist es natürlich, alle Experimente so erfolgreich wie möglich zu fliegen. Es ist natürlich sehr kooperativ, aber trotzdem eben ein critical design review.
Ja, das fand ich auch sehr schön. Ich bin selber da so reingegangen und dachte mir so, was wird jetzt wohl... Ich hatte ja nichts zu befürchten. Ich habe mich nur gefragt, auf welchem Level findet jetzt eigentlich diese Auseinandersetzung damit statt. Die Gruppe muss ja dann so ein Paper vorlegen, relativ umfangreiche Dokumentation, wo dann alle, ich weiß nicht, ob es muss, aber in dem Fall war es so.
Es ist schon so. Wir brauchen natürlich eine Dokumentation. Und es gibt ein sogenanntes SED, eine Student Experiment Documentation. Und das ist so ein lebendes Dokument, sagt man glaube ich immer so schön. Da stellen wir ein Template zur Verfügung. Und das wird am Anfang des Projektes angelegt. Und da werden alle Aspekte dieses Experiments oder dieses Projekts aufgerollt. Also da sollte alles drinstehen, über die Konstruktion, über die Mechanik, über die elektrische Konstruktion. Da werden eben auch Schallpläne reingemalt. Da werden eben diese CAD-Zeichnungen reingemalt. Da sollte auch drinstehen, was soll das Experiment überhaupt, was ist hin und zweck einer Sache, welchen wissenschaftlichen Mehrwert erhoffen wir uns. Da steht auch drin, welche Tests müssen wir zum Beispiel machen, was ist wichtig für unser Experiment. Da schreibt man auch rein, ganz ganz wichtig, wie schwer wird unser Experiment werden. Wie vorher schon erwähnt, der kritische Punkt, den es gibt in der Raketengeschichte, ist immer die Masse. Deswegen sind wir auch ganz stark darauf bedacht, dass die Masse in einem gewissen Limit bleibt. Dann steht natürlich auch drin, wie stellen wir uns das Projektmanagement vor? Das ist also auch eine ganz wichtige Sache, die, glaube ich, auch dieses Rexus, Bexus insgesamt so interessant macht, weil das hat ein Student so schön zu mir gesagt, wenn ich das zitieren darf, das ist eine Sache, die kann die Uni nicht bieten. Also an der Uni lernst du zwar, du hast Vorlesungen und Übungen und kriegst eine fachliche Kompetenz, aber wirklich ein Projekt als Team durchzuführen und sich da selber zu managen. Ich meine, das sind ja Leute, die finden sich zusammen. Dann müssen die erstmal einen gemeinsamen Konsens finden. Der eine sagt vielleicht, ich stelle mir vor, dass wir es so machen, der andere sagt, ich stelle mir vor, dass wir es aber anders machen. Und dann müssen die sich ja quasi zusammen raufen und sagen, okay, so konzipieren wir das. Dann müssen die sich eine Projektmanagementstruktur überlegen. Wir haben ja einen vorgegebenen Zeitplan. Wie gesagt, es gibt diesen Termin fürs PDA, dann fürs CDA. Und dann ist ja auch klar, wann die Kampagne kommt, spätestens in eineinhalb Jahren. Dass man sich auch überlegt, welchen Schritt müssen wir bis wann erledigt haben? Was müssen wir bis wann schaffen? Wann müssen wir die Teile ordnen? Wann können wir die Tests machen? Wann müssen wir uns darum kümmern, dass wir die Testeinrichtung überhaupt bekommen? Wer macht wann was? Und dann was natürlich dazukommt, das Ganze findet ja meistens nebenher des Studiums statt. Das heißt, es gibt auch noch Prüfungen, es sind Vorlesungen zu bearbeiten. Und das ist eine Sache, die auch zeigt, mit welcher Leidenschaft oder welchem Enthusiasmus diese Studenten eigentlich da bei der Sache sind. Ich bin da echt immer zutiefst beeindruckt, wenn Studenten das neben dem Studium noch hermachen, das so auf die Reihe zu kriegen. Und diese Teamfähigkeit, diese Planungsfähigkeit einfach zu lernen, ich glaube, das ist eine unersetzliche Erfahrung, auch wenn man später mal in großen Projekten mitarbeiten will, dass man das einfach so am Stück geboten kriegt. Und natürlich ganz toll, es kommt am Ende immer was bei RUM, nämlich zumindest der Raketenstart, selbst wenn das Experiment, was eigentlich sehr selten vorkommt, gar nicht funktioniert hat, dann hat man immerhin diesen Projektzyklus durchlaufen, hat den Raketen- oder Ballonstart miterlebt, kann danach noch eine Fehleranalyse machen, warum hat es nicht funktioniert, aber man hat wirklich ein Ziel vor Augen. Weil es gibt ja viele studentische Projekte, die sehr langfristig angelegt sind und vielleicht auch viel großartiger oder scheinbar großartiger angelegt sind, wo aber die eine Generation, die es anfängt zu planen, gar nicht mehr mitkriegt, wie es dann letztendlich fliegt, irgendwelche Satellitengeschichten zum Beispiel oder so was. Oder die dann teilweise auch eingestampft werden aus Geldgründen, weil man sagt, ja, das können wir jetzt doch nicht mehr durchführen und dann haben zwei Generationen von Studenten daran gearbeitet, um dann plötzlich zu erfahren, muss leider gestritten werden. Das passiert bei Rexus, Bexus definitiv nicht. Das ist sicher auch ein hoher Motivationsgrund. Wenn du da anfängst, weißt du, ich werde meinen Ballon fliegen sehen.
Findet auch auf jeden Fall statt.
Findet auf jeden Fall statt.
Weiter mal zurück auf diese Situation in diesem Raum. Was ich nicht ganz mitbekommen habe, ist, wie das so präsentiert wurde, aber ich nehme an, die sind dann einfach Stück für Stück durch das Design durchgegangen und haben vorgestellt, wie dann so ihre Implementierung aus...
Ja, die machen am Anfang eine Präsentation, also wirklich 20 Minuten, Viertelstunde, paar Folien darstellen. Was haben wir gemacht, wie stellen wir es uns vor, warum passt es? Und dann wird es aufgedreht. Dann wird der Spieß umgedreht.
Genau, dann geht man so strukturiert durch, greift sich die einzelnen Kategorien, die einzelnen Aspekte, unter denen das Ganze zu bewerten ist, raus. Und dann melden sich entweder die zuständigen Experten, manche haben auch zu anderen Bereichen was zu sagen, also im Prinzip kann sich da jeder äußern. Und man versucht erst mal, auf die wesentlichen, die großen Sachen zu konzentrieren. Wenn da noch Raum ist, werden auch noch Kleinigkeiten angegeben. Und ich fand besonders diese Kleinigkeiten eigentlich sehr interessant, wo man auch so ein bisschen gemerkt hat, mit welcher Akribie diese Pläne auch wirklich betrachtet werden. Was ja auch nicht ganz unwichtig ist, weil es ja eben auch auf die Kleinigkeiten ankommt. Auf der anderen Seite auch Sachen genannt wurden, die eher so ganz praktische kleine Tipps waren. Zum Beispiel gab es ganz allgemeine Sachen, wie die Begrenzung, die ist irgendwie 5 mm, das muss aber 4,8 mm sein. Dann passt das irgendwie besser rein. Das ist so ein, so muss es sein, und wenn es anders ist, dann ist es falsch, dann wird es nicht funktionieren. Weil passt nicht, geht nicht, lässt keinen Raum oder wie auch immer. Aber dann gibt es auch so Anmerkungen, die eben so waren. Ja, hier guckt mal, da in eurer Elektronik, da habt ihr dann irgendwie so zwei Stecker, wo man was ranstecken kann. Und die sind aber beide Female Plugs. Und auch wenn das jetzt erstmal von der Funktionalität her ist, ist da nichts falsch. Man meint einfach nur so, wenn ihr unter Stress seid, dann steckt ihr bestimmt den falschen irgendwo drauf. Macht da mal den einen irgendwie so rum und den anderen so rum, also Male Plug, Female Plug und so weiter. Und schon kann euch da an der Stelle nichts passieren. Das fand ich dann doch wirklich so ein... Also es wird sozusagen nicht nur kritisiert, sondern es wird einfach mitgedacht. Es wird mitentwickelt und auch viel Erfahrung dort reingegeben.
Das Ganze soll ja auch einen Lerneffekt für die Studenten bringen. Und den Lerneffekt kriegst du natürlich nur dadurch, dass du den Leuten Tipps gibst, dass du sie motivierst. Das bringt natürlich gar nichts wie überall, wenn man einfach nur sagt, das ist scheiße, das ist scheiße, das ist scheiße, ich geh wieder nach Hause, ist ganz klar. Und gerade ist interessant, dass dir das aufgefallen ist mit diesen Tipps zum Beispiel. Das sind zum Beispiel einfach Details, die man vielleicht jetzt auch nicht unbedingt lernt, wenn man nur Vorlesungen hört, sondern eher, wenn man mal so ein praktisches Projekt durchführt. Ich mein, man ist dann in dieser Situation, man ist auf der Kampagne, man ist in Kiruna. Und allein, dass man zum Beispiel an so triviale Sachen denkt, wie hab ich mein komplettes Werkzeug dabei? Hab ich für alles, für was ich Ersatzteile bräuchte, auch wirklich Ersatzteile dabei. Weil, wenn man in Kiruna oder in S-Range auf der Range ist und Kampagnesituation ist, und in fünf Tagen ist der Countdown angesetzt, und irgendeine letzte Änderung muss am Experiment noch gemacht werden, was normalerweise, übrigens nebenbei bemerkt, nicht mehr vorkommen sollte. Wir verlangen also eigentlich schon, dass das Experiment vorher abgeliefert wird, und zwar in dem Zustand, dass es flugfähig ist, aber...
Man weiß ja nie. Da kann man nicht mal eben noch im Baumarkt fahren.
Da kann man nicht eben noch mal im Baumarkt fahren und sagen, Mensch, ich brauche jetzt noch schnell eine M6-Schraube, und dieses und jenes. Ja, dass man auf solche Dinge achtet. Und eben auch zum Beispiel, wenn man dann unter Stress steht, dass man nichts verwechselt, dass man alles markiert, dass man wirklich, da sind wir auch wieder beim Thema Management, dass man eine genaue Idee hat von den Prozessabläufen, die zu machen sind, und auch wer macht was, wer hat welche Zuständigkeiten, dass sich die Leute da auch nicht gegenseitig ins Gehege kommen usw. Aber ich muss sagen, soweit ich das bisher mitgekriegt habe, diese Teams, es ist wirklich bewundernswert, also top organisiert im Normalfall, top organisiert. Die kriegen das echt auf die Reihe.
Das ist beeindruckend, wenn man das sieht. Gab es einen zweiten Punkt, der mir aufgefallen ist? Ich hatte schon so ein bisschen gehofft, weil es ging dann irgendwie viel um Mechanik und Passform und Elektronik und natürlich so Anforderungen und wie viel Strom wird da verbraucht und was fließen da für Ströme etc. Also auch Sicherheitsanforderungen, thermale Anforderungen.
Ganz wichtig, selbstverständlich.
Das sind natürlich alles so Sachen. Thermal gab es da jetzt glaube ich nicht so viel zu meckern. Dann kam es dann aber Gott sei Dank auch noch zur Software.
Das ist eher dein Ding, oder?
Was einerseits jetzt von mir so ein bisschen so eine Liebe ist, aber wo ich sage mal, ich meine Software hat ja auch noch mal so einen ganz eigenen Komplexitätsgrad. Die Sache, die dann aber moniert wurde, war, in irgendeinem Flowchart gab es dann so, ja, hier steht was von Test-Mode aktivieren. Man merkt nicht so richtig so auf der Gegenseite, war so ein bisschen so, ja und so. Was kann da jetzt dran falsch sein? Also Test-Mode ist eigentlich keine gute Sache. Geht gar nicht davon aus, dass ihr jemals in einem Test-Mode seid. Geht einfach immer davon aus, dass ihr immer im Flug-Modus seid. Weil sonst habt ihr irgendwann so den Fall, dass die Software eigentlich alles richtig macht, aber irgendwie in dem falschen Modus ist und so weiter. Das ist so ein bisschen so ähnlich wie mit den Steckern, aber eben auf so einer Software-Ebene. Einfach auch an der Stelle, also man merkt einfach, das will ich sagen, dass das Team da mit einer ungeheuren Erfahrung am Start war. Also die haben schon irgendwie alles Blutensehen, das merkt man sofort. Aber auf der anderen Seite...
Also du meinst das Expertenteam ist?
Das Expertenteam, genau.
Die haben schon selbstverständlich viel Blutensehen.
Genau, das merkt man auch so. Trotzdem war das einfach auch wirklich eine extrem kollegiale, gelöste Situation. Also man war irgendwie ernsthaft bei der Sache. Aber es war auch sehr, ja, freundschaftlich ist das nicht das richtige Wort. Aber es war einfach, wie soll man sagen, kooperativ.
So soll es ja auch sein.
So soll es sein, so war es auch.
Ja.
Also das ist aus meiner Perspektive. Und dann auch viele Hinweise auch so bei Software. Es war immer so dieses, seid ihr euch sicher, dass ihr da keinen Fehler gemacht habt? Ja, so der Interrupt und so weiter. Da habt ihr so Latenzen und so habt ihr das dann auch wirklich bedacht. Und dann auf der anderen Seite so, ja wieso, was soll da schiefgehen? Und so winkt ihr nur so ab und mal so, naja, okay, wenn ihr euch sicher seid, seid ihr euch sicher, denkt drüber nochmal nach.
Es ist halt so, wir haben halt viele Erfahrungen schon gemacht, auch mit vielen Experimenten. Auch wenn wir jetzt nicht direkt mit den Experimenten zu tun haben. Aber jedes dieser Experimente und man kann eigentlich was sagen, jede Rexus-Rakete ist im Endeffekt ein Prototyp. Und wenn du Prototypen hast, dann können eben immer unvorhergesehene Dinge passieren. Das ist was anderes, als wenn ich Autos oder Flugzeuge am Fließband passiere. Die müssen funktionieren. Da habe ich ein ganz anderes Qualitätsmanagementsystem, ein ganz anderes Ausschusssystem, was Fehler betrifft. Wenn die ein Experiment bauen, dann ist es ein Prototyp und die bauen es zum ersten Mal. Da kann wahnsinnig viel schiefgehen. Es gab natürlich auch schon Fälle, dass wir... Ein Experiment, erinnere ich mich zum Beispiel, das hat sehr gut funktioniert. In dem Moment, wo die Rakete startet, gibt es ein Lift-off-Signal. Dieses Signal kann Verschiedenes in den Experimenten auslösen. Das führt meistens dazu, dass das Experiment anläuft. Das ist naiv gesprochen. Bei diesem Experiment war es dann so, in dem Moment, wo die Rakete gezündet hat und dieses Lift-off-Signal kam, hat sich das abgeschaltet. Keine Ahnung, warum. Das ist halt Lernen durch Schmerzen. Die war natürlich ganz betrübt. Aber solche Sachen versucht man dadurch zu vermeiden.
Ich würde jetzt ganz gerne zum Schluss noch mal auf die eigentliche Kampagne, also das Kampagnenende, also den Start, noch mal kurz eingehen, bevor wir das machen. Du hattest vorhin noch diese, wie heißt das, genannte Scientific Payload Integration Week.
Um das vielleicht kurz zu Ende zu bringen, also nach diesem Critical Design Review, wenn alles passt, dann wird die Hardware gebaut. Dann gibt es auch einen Termin, wo praktisch das Experiment, also es ist so, dass die Kollegen aus Bremen, die für die studentische Experimentbetreuung auch zuständig sind und das koordinieren und managen, die fahren dann auch nochmal zu den Teams hin, schauen sich die Hardware an, sofern es nötig ist, ob wirklich alles passt, um da nochmal drüber zu gucken. Dann gibt es einen Termin, das Experiment Acceptance Review, wo dann die Nutzlast in Bremen abgegeben wird. Das ist praktisch der Termin, wo eigentlich gewünscht wäre, dass die Studenten zum letzten Mal an ihrem Experiment wirklich dran sind. Das ist auch verknüpft mit dieser Integration Payload Week. Da wird also die Nutzlast, also diese Experiment-Module, zusammenverkabelt, zusammengesteckt. Dann wird geschaut, ob das alles funktioniert.
Also sozusagen das erste Mal, wo wirklich alle Experimente zusammenkommen.
Das muss man ja mal machen. Das kann man auch nicht oft genug machen. Ein ganz wichtiger Punkt dann, zumindest für das... Ich spreche jetzt immer ein bisschen mehr für die Raketenseite, weil ich da natürlich mehr drin involviert bin als Mitarbeiter der mobilen Raketenbasis. Bei Ballonen läuft es aber relativ ähnlich. Das findet da meistens im Januar statt. Das ist der sogenannte Benchtest. Da werden dann die Experimente von Bremen hier nach Oberpfaffenhofen verfrachtet. Und bei diesem Benchtest wird die gesamte Nutzlast wirklich zusammengebaut. Das heißt, da wird dann auch das tatsächlich zu fliegende Service-System und das tatsächlich zu fliegende Recovery oder falschen Bergungssystem mit der Payload zusammengeschraubt und dann wird eine komplette Timeline durchgelaufen. Dann wird gesehen, ob wirklich alles funktioniert oder ob sich irgendwas gegenseitig blockiert, ob irgendwelche Signale nicht funktionieren. Was während so einem Flug stattfindet, eben nochmal, weil ich den Begriff Timeline erwähnt habe, das ist alles von, ja, man kann sich das vorstellen, wie wenn da eine große imaginäre Uhr im Hintergrund läuft und dann hat man verschiedene Ereignisse während dem Raketenflug, zum Beispiel Abtrennung des Motors, Abtrennung der Nasenspitze, Aktivierung von Experiment 1, Aktivierung der Datenspeicherung von Experiment 2, was weiß ich. Dann haben wir zum Beispiel auch Experimente, die einen Boom aus der Rakete ausgefahren haben oder einen Teleskop arm, das muss ja zum Beispiel auch irgendwie aktiviert werden.
Was ist ein Boom?
Boom, das ist letztendlich einfach eine Stange, die nach außen geführt wird. Ich weiß auch nicht genau, warum man das Boom nennt, aber da gab es ein Experiment, die haben einen Teleskopic-Boom gemacht. Nach dem Teleskop-Prinzip haben die einen Arm ausgefahren. Da kann man am Ende irgendeinen Sensor dranhängen, um Messungen zu machen. Da ging es auch um so einen Technologie-Demonstrator. Das sind alles Ereignisse, die im Rahmen dieser Timeline ablaufen und dann eben auch über das Service-System gesteuert werden. Dieses ganze Zusammenspiel, das wird bei dem Benchtest zum ersten Mal wirklich komplett durchgeführt mit allen Originalsystemen, so wie sie dann auch in Kiruna fliegen werden.
Und jedes Experiment, was diesen Test dann auch besteht, darf dann auch letzten Endes?
Die Experimente sollten diese Tests alle bestehen, weil sie ja vorher auch schon auf dieser Integration-Payload-Week schon mal Tests gemacht haben und natürlich die fliegen dann alle mit nach Kiruna. In Kiruna macht man dann diesen Benchtest nochmal. Wie gesagt, das kann man nicht oft genug machen. Der letzte große Test vor dem eigentlichen großen Ereignis, dem Start, ist dann der Test-Countdown oder auch mehrere Test-Countdowns, wenn nötig. Da ist dann die Rakete komplett zusammengebaut, auch mit dem Motor und hängt an dem Launcher in Kiruna und dann wird ein kompletter Countdown durchgefahren. Allerdings ohne, dass das Liftoff-Signal gesendet wird.
Okay, aber zumindest so bis dahin muss auch schon mal alles richtig reagieren?
Bis dahin muss alles richtig reagieren. Das ist also die allerletzte Chance, wo man dann noch eingreifen könnte, wenn man feststellt, dass irgendwas gar nicht geht. Gut, da muss man natürlich... Angenommen ist zum Glück noch nicht so wirklich passiert. Ein Experiment würde während des Test-Countdowns total versagen und auch man hätte keine Ahnung mehr, wie man das zum Laufen bringt. Da müsste man sich natürlich überlegen, starten wir trotzdem oder starten wir nicht? Also bei einem sehr teuren, millionenschweren Industrieprojekt wartet man halt einfach so lange, dass das bezahlt die Industrie, wenn die das so haben wollen.
Kann denn ein einzelnes Experiment softwaretechnisch einen Startabbruch verursachen?
Nein, nicht, dass ich wüsste. Es kommt ja darauf an, was du genau mit Startabbruch meinst.
Also nach dem Motto, ich hab nicht die richtigen Messergebnisse, lass lieber noch mal 10 Minuten später starten.
Ach so, hab nicht die richtigen Messergebnisse, lass 10 Minuten später starten.
Es gibt ja auch bei richtigen Starts, bei großen Raketen gibt es ja auch immer solche Sachen, wo dann noch mal 15 Minuten später...
Wenn du natürlich sowas meinst, dafür ist ja der Test-Countdown da. Wenn ich während dem Test-Countdown feststelle, ein Experiment hat sonst immer funktioniert, kriegt jetzt während dem Test-Countdown plötzlich keine Daten, dann wird man natürlich alles daransetzen, dass diese Schwachstelle behoben wird und die wieder Daten empfangen können. Da wird auch zur Not noch mal um den Tag verschoben? Da wird auch zur Not, kann man auch um den Tag verschieben. Ich hatte vorher erwähnt, im Schnitt haben wir vier, fünf Experimente auf einer Rakete, wenn jetzt drei von vier nicht gehen würden, was auch noch nie vorkam, dann braucht man natürlich auch nicht starten, weil dann ist es ja alles nur bei Lastmasse und im Endeffekt...
Diese Zone, über die dann geflogen wird, ist das generell so ein Sperrgebiet oder muss das dann auch explizit vorher gesperrt werden?
Nein, das ist kein generelles Sperrgebiet. Das ist absolut menschenleeres Gebiet, ganz im Norden von Schweden. Da gibt es Leute, die da drin wohnen, allerdings ist die Bevölkerungsdichte extrem gering. Das sind eben diese einheimischen Völker, Lappen und Samen. Die wissen aber, dass diese Raketen-Stats stattfinden. Die Stats werden natürlich auch vorher angekündigt. Dieses ganze operationelle Startprozedere, obliegt der Hoheit der Esrange. Weil es ist ein schwedisches Hoheitsgebiet. Die Esrange hat praktisch das letzte Wort, was sämtliche Sicherheitsbestimmungen betrifft. Man muss sich auch darum kümmern, dass das ganze dem schwedischen Luftamt gemeldet wird. Dass es rechtzeitig angekündigt wird. Und die erfahren das auch, wann ein Raketenstart ist. Da gibt es auch Bunker, in die die sich zurückziehen könnten, um irgendwelchen Gefahren zu entgehen. Aber um ganz ehrlich zu sein, diese Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass, wenn diese Nutzlast am Fallschirm zurückkommt oder auch der Motor runterfällt, dass sich das trifft, die ist ja gleich Null. Dafür ist das Gebiet so groß, extrem gering. Da müsste es schon mit dem Teufel zu gehen. Aber gut, man weiß nie. Insofern warnt man die Leute natürlich schon vor.
Wenn das jetzt alles gelaufen ist und alle glücklich vor sich hingelöhen...
Dann gibt es die Kampagnenparty.
Dann gibt es die Kampagnenparty. Und irgendwann ist der Spaß ja dann auch vorbei. Was kann man denn so sagen über die langfristige Bedeutung dieser Experimente jetzt für die Studenten und vielleicht auch darüber hinaus? Also gibt es irgendwelche Erkenntnisse, dass schon aus diesen Experimenten mehr als jetzt nur der eigentliche Lernerfolg herausgekommen ist, sondern dass das dann, keine Ahnung, Karrieren vorbereitet hat, schon auch neue Technologien angeschoben hat? Ich will jetzt nicht so sehr auf Success Stories hinaus, sondern einfach nur so ein bisschen so rauslesen, welche Bedeutung auch solche, diese Rexus, Bexus-Kampagnen so haben für diesen Ausbildungsweg, sowohl konkret für die Studenten als eben auch für den ganzen Lernprozess in der Raumfahrt?
Also ein Bestandteil des Projektes ist es schon auch, Ich glaube, es ist schon auch die Studenten dazu anzuhalten, ja sogenannten Outreach zu machen. Das wird auch sehr intensiv betrieben. Natürlich gibt es Facebook-Seiten, jedes Team hat seine eigene Homepage. Aber um mehr auf das Wissenschaftliche zu kommen, im Idealfall ist schon das Ziel, dass dabei, also zumindest bei einem wissenschaftlichen Experiment, dass man vielleicht sogar eine Veröffentlichung macht, in einer Fachzeitschrift hat es auch schon gegeben. Es gibt in dieser Sounding-Rocket- und Ballon-Community gibt es alle zwei Jahre eine Konferenz über Forschungsraketen und Ballonforschung. Im Endeffekt so ein großes Familientreffen. Da werden die Studenten auch noch mal gesponsert, die dürfen da hinfahren und sind auch angehalten, ihre Ergebnisse dort vorzutragen und in den Konferenzproceedings zu publizieren. Also da passiert schon einiges. Weil du sagst, die Bedeutung für den Ausbildungsweg. Also ich kann es eigentlich jetzt gerade nur so formulieren. Also wenn ich ein Personaler oder ein Headhunter wäre und jemand kommt mit der Erfahrung Rexus, Bexus, dann würde ich den sofort nehmen. Weil wie gesagt, ich habe diese Leute kennengelernt. Es sind wahnsinnig intelligente Leute, die eben viel Leidenschaft an den Tag legen. Wie gesagt, es durchzuziehen. Manche, die das mit ihrem Studium nicht vereinbaren können, die setzen sogar ein Semester aus, um sich diesem Projekt zu widmen. Weil sich das einfach lohnt. Weil sich das einfach lohnt, um einfach auch als Erfahrung so was mitgemacht zu haben. Es wäre natürlich schön, das liegt auch nicht in unserer Macht als ausführendes Organ für dieses Projekt, aber es wäre natürlich schön und passiert, auch Gott sei Dank häufig, wenn diese Teilnahme an dem Projekt in universitäre Leistungen umgesetzt werden kann. Es gab schon Diplomarbeiten, die über Rexus-Projekte geben, auch Doktorarbeiten.
Aber es ist nicht die Regel?
Es ist nicht die Regel, nicht unbedingt. Und das ist natürlich schon eine Sache, gerade heutzutage, glaube ich, mit diesem neuen Bachelor-Master-System, was doch viel strenger ist als dieses freiere Studieren, was es früher gab, ist es doch schwieriger, sich für sowas zu entscheiden, was eigentlich schade ist. Weil, wie gesagt, ich rede auch viel mit den Studenten und es hat mir eigentlich noch keiner gesagt, es war irgendwie totaler Quatsch. Also im Gegenteil, die Begeisterung ist überbordend. Jeder sagt, ich habe hier so viel gelernt, wie in den letzten zehn Jahren nicht. Und abgesehen natürlich von der Erfahrung an sich. Also wer kommt schon dazu, mal nach S-Venge zu fahren und einen Ballon starten oder eine Rakete starten zu sehen?
Genau, und ich meine auch die Zahl der Wissenschaftsleiter, die jetzt wirklich konkret an Raumfahrtmissionen dann letztlich auch wirklich beteiligen. Ich meine, es gibt ja keine Garantie dafür, dass wenn man jetzt auch vielleicht auf Raumfahrt zielt oder generell einfach in einem wissenschaftlichen Bereich arbeitet, wo dann Raumfahrt irgendwann noch mal ein Thema sein kann, wo die eigene Disziplin mit irgendeiner Mission vielleicht mal den Mittelpunkt gestellt. Das ist ja nicht garantiert, dass man an sowas teilnehmen kann. Die Erfahrung schon mal gemacht zu haben und dann eben auch als Ausbildungsbasis vorweisen zu können. So hier, ich habe schon mal eineinhalb Jahre Projektmanagement gemacht und ich weiß, wie die Anforderungen sind. Das ist natürlich was wert.
Und man knüpft natürlich, das ist vielleicht auch ein wichtiger Aspekt, jede Menge Beziehungen. Also erstens, die Leute lernen sich natürlich untereinander kennen. Also die Teams haben teilweise auch eine sehr internationale Zusammensetzung. Also ich kann mich zum Beispiel noch erinnern, das war ein Team, ich glaube, das waren Franzosen. Und da hat der Bremer-Kollege zu mir gesagt, also ich weiß nicht so recht, die haben einen, ich glaube, es war ein Japaner im Team und der kann kein Französisch. Und die Franzosen können kein Japanisch, aber wie zur Hölle kommunizieren die? Und der war aber Fachmann für irgendwas und trotzdem haben die das hingekriegt und sich auszutauschen. Die Teams knüpfen untereinander, Kontakte, auch die Zusammenarbeit zwischen den Teams ist hervorragend, ist vielleicht auch ein Aspekt, der zu betonen ist, es ist kein Konkurrenzdenken, sondern vielleicht ist es auch wirklich so eine Sache, wenn fünf Experimente gemeinsam auf einer Ballongondel oder auf einer Rakete sind und sich gegenseitig nicht stören dürfen, dann erfordert das schon so eine gewisse Zusammenarbeit, eine gewisse Teamfähigkeit. Und ich hab auch nie erlebt, dass die Teams sich versuchen, gegenseitig auszustechen oder sowas. Im Gegenteil, die helfen sich gegenseitig. Also wenn der eine sagt, ich hab keinen Schraubenzieher, gebt mir einen, ja ganz banal jetzt dann kriegen die den, aber die interessieren sich auch füreinander. Mensch, was macht ihr denn, wie habt ihr das Problem gelöst und so weiter. Und das sind ja alles Leute, die in der gleichen Generation aufwachsen und der ein oder andere wird vielleicht mal ein Space-Manager von denen und sagt dann, Mensch, ich kenn noch den noch, den könnten wir brauchen oder irgendwie sowas. Und auf der anderen Seite lernen die natürlich auch uns kennen. Die Leute vom DLR, die Leute von SSC, Leute von ESA. Also es ist zum Beziehungen knüpfen ideal.
Ja, Alexander, ich glaube unsere Reise, unsere Parabel nähert sich dem Fallschirm. Genau, wir segeln eigentlich schon seit ein paar Minuten der Erde entgegen. Und wenn wir jetzt nicht noch etwas ganz wichtiges, dringendes ausgelassen haben, was wir noch anstellen könnten?
Was ich vielleicht noch erwähnen könnte ist, wenn sich jemand für dieses Projekt interessiert, unbedingt auf die Homepage Rexus Bexus schauen. Rexus Bexus, also klein und zusammengeschrieben. Dort findet man alle relevanten Informationen. Dort findet man, genau beschrieben, was man tun muss, um sich zu bewerben, wann die nächste Ausschreibung ist. Wie dieses ganze Prozedere läuft, ganz interessant auch. Ich glaube, wir hatten fast 60 Experimente jetzt in den letzten Jahren. Es sind die einzelnen Experimente aufgelistet. Da kann man sich Ideen holen, Anregungen, kann schauen, was haben die anderen gemacht, was könnte ich machen. Und kann sich dadurch dieses ganze Sammelsurium durcharbeiten. Dann, auch ganz wichtig, gibt es auf dieser Seite das Rexus User Manual und auch das Bexus User Manual. Das sind Dokumente, die wir im Laufe der Jahre erstellt haben, in denen letztendlich genau beschrieben ist, wie eine Kampagne abläuft und was die technischen Schnittstellen und Anforderungen sind, um ein Experiment auf einem Ballon oder einer Rakete zu starten. Schon mal so als erstes, was muss ich überhaupt beachten, was geht gar nicht. Das kann man sich anschauen, dieses Dokument, dann hat man schon mal eine Vorstellung. Was auch interessant ist, wenn man vielleicht mal ein bisschen stöbert, auf YouTube gibt es eine Menge Videos, vielleicht einfach mal auf YouTube Rexus eingeben oder Bexus, da findet man einige interessante Filme. Und es ist in der Tat wirklich erstaunlich, was teilweise auch als Nebenprodukt für Videos inzwischen schon produziert wurden mit diesen neuen GoPro-Kameras. Da kann man ja ganz tolle Filme machen und das sind Top-Videos. Da werden Filme gemacht vom Start der Rakete bis zur Fallschirmssequenz. Die können sich also wirklich sehen lassen. Kann man von NASA-Filmen nicht unterscheiden. Da findet sich einiges, was einem so einen gewissen Eindruck gibt. Da findet man auch Videos vom Ballonstarts, von Raketenstarts. Damit kann man sich, glaube ich, einen ganz guten Eindruck verschaffen von der Geschichte. Ich kann jedem interessierten Studenten aus Naturwissenschaft und Technik nur raten. Schaut euch die Sache an. Die Erfahrung ist es, glaube ich, wert. Wenn ihr eine gute Idee habt, macht mit.
Okay. Das lassen wir jetzt mal so im Raum stehen. Ich danke dir auch, Tim. Das war es hier, der Einblick in die spezielle Verbindung von Raumfahrt und Studenten-Dasein, was vielleicht manche von euch auch mal in der Zukunft interessieren sollte. Ja, ich sage vielen Dank an Alexander. Vielen Dank an euch fürs Zuhören. Hier geht es bald weiter. Ich sage Tschüss und bis bald bei Raumzeit.